Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
So, ich bin es.
Sag mal, was ist mit den Qualitätsoptionen los?
Habt ihr Source-Quality beziehungsweise 1080p?
Nee, oder?
Gibt's bei euch Source-Quality beziehungsweise könnt ihr 1080p einstellen?
Bei mir gibt's bloß irgendwie 720p mit kack Auflösung.
Oh man, ey, diese Twitch-Encoding-Settings, das ist so ein Crap.
Ich ändere nix an den Settings und jedes Mal sieht's anders aus.
Das letzte Mal mit exakt den gleichen Settings durfte ich nur in 1080p und nix anderem.
Nee, jetzt geht's. Guck mal, jetzt geht's. Jetzt ist 1080p-Quelle da.
Jetzt geht's. Erst mal aufregen. Aufregen hilft immer.
Erst mal Range-Mode an. Eats.
Jetzt muss er mal refreshen. Guck mal, jetzt ist 1080p da.
Ja, also ohne Kirby-Musik werde ich das Ganze halt wahrscheinlich nicht aushalten.
Erst mal die ganzen Krämpel hier aufmachen, Twitter posten.
Wir spielen erst mal ne Runde bevor ich das auf Twitter poste.
Weil ich hab quasi seitdem wir das letzte Mal Battlefield gespielt haben,
nix Großartiges mehr Battlefield-mäßig gespielt.
Es hat eigentlich gar nix.
Wann kann man auf YouTube wieder mit dir rechnen?
Sobald es ein Spiel gibt, was mir Spaß macht und sobald YouTube als Plattform nicht so sehr auf den Sack geht.
So, erst mal den Vogel wegmachen. Text weg. Vogel weg.
Wir müssen erst mal gucken, ob Sound-Lautstärke und so okay ist.
Und ihr müsst mir ja mal kurz erzählen, ob man in-Game hat.
Ich muss mal einen Vorschau anmachen, ob man in-Game alles sieht.
Conquest. Grand Operations.
Das haben wir das letzte Mal gespielt. Es hat mich letztes Mal so aufgeregt.
Grand Operations, spielen wir jetzt wieder.
Und ich muss mal Discord anmachen.
Also ich sehe, ob der Eax was schreibt.
Also er wollte, glaube ich, nachher mitspielen.
Oder er spielt WoW, eins von beiden.
Er hat aber was geschrieben.
So, jetzt müssen wir erst mal gucken, wie die Limit-Lautstärke ist.
Ob das was taugt.
Also die Lautstärke muss lauter als die Kirby-Musik sein.
Wir können ein bisschen lauter machen, oder?
Alle spielen WoW.
Alter, WoW.
WoW. Oh, wat?
Wurde ich gerade im Spawn gesniped oder so? Kann das sein?
Moment, die Sensitivity stimmt mal wieder überhaupt nicht.
Ich brauche jetzt ein halbes Maus-Pad für ein C6 hier. Das ist eigentlich zu schnell.
Boah!
War ja schon fast down.
Alle spielen WoW. Ja, WoW in MMX.
Was ist da? Ich hab sogar im Titel stehen.
In MMX V111.
Römische Nummern.
2K18. Oh, wurde ich gerettet? Nein, wurde ich gerettet.
Aber WoW. WoW ist ein Game.
Guck mal, das Ding hat ein neues Eigen.
Schau mal, Kirby im Ticken, da ist er.
Aber es muss immer noch laut genug sein, dass ich nicht durchdrehe.
Auch wenn man das jetzt nicht denkt, dass die Musik jetzt eigentlich eher dazu führt, dass man durchdreht,
bei dem Game ist es eher so, dass mich das beruhigt.
So, was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
MP40.
Links hier.
Gewehr 3. Warte, das war Schneiber. Schneiber-Action, ne?
Guck mal.
Oh, kennt ihr das noch?
Erinnert mich an das letzte... Oh, man kann die Tür nicht mehr durch die...
Doch, man kann die Tür immer noch durch die Wand aufmachen.
Das hat mich das letzte Mal sehr verwirrt.
Man rennt langsamer?
Oder?
Man rennt... Ich hab das Gefühl, man rennt langsamer.
Man hängt an jedem... Seht ihr das? Man hängt an jedem Scheiß fest.
Oh je. Draw... Ne, wie ging das? Draw, FPS...
Draw, Perf, Overlay...
Ne, ach du Scheiße.
Perf, Overlay, Draw, FPS.
So war's.
Genau, das sehen wir nämlich schon, was wir hier haben.
Es ruckelt.
Na gut, die Performance das letzte Mal war ja auch schon grausam.
Die Performance ist immer noch mega schlecht.
Also, wohlgemerkt, ne?
Ich hab das Schnellste, was so ziemlich geht.
Sowohl an Grafikkarte als auch an CPU, also.
Ach nee, spotten geht ja gar nicht, immer mit Q.
Fücken geht alles richtig.
Kann man hier drüber hüpfen?
Okay, ich check wieder null, wo die Gegner herkommen.
Verwirrt mich wieder.
Wir stellen uns jetzt da in die Ecke und gucken einfach runter.
Ja, das ist gar kein Gegner.
Aber wir haben's gepackt.
Oh, es ruckelt. Es ruckelt.
Warum ruckelt das doch?
Das hat es das letzte Mal.
Oh fuck, was ist hinten links?
Komm her.
Klamate, G.
Wir sprayen einfach mal drauf.
Über Range draufsprayen, Beste.
Kann man nix schief, kann man nix verkehrt machen.
Warum seh ich die überhaupt durch das Smoke?
Was soll denn das? Warum seh ich Gegner durch den Smoke?
The fuck?
Warum seh ich Gegner durch den Smoke?
Das ist nicht so gedacht, oder?
Ist Lautstärke jetzt okay?
Okay, Moment, wir stellen das jetzt.
Warte mal, was hatten wir das letzte Mal für eine Waffe?
Das Ding, das war doch ganz nice.
Wie konnte man den Scheiß noch mal customisieren?
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie das ging.
Hat jemand eine Ahnung, wie lange die aktuelle Alpha reinsprühen und beten?
Hat jemand eine Ahnung?
Wir sind 50.000 Gegner.
Also man läuft langsamer, hab ich das Gefühl zumindest.
Oder es leckt einfach nur.
Aber ich hab das Gefühl, man läuft langsamer.
Kommt mir zumindest so vor.
Wo ist er?
Ah, zweiter.
Alter, bleib liegen.
Hören wir mal das Granat drüber.
Ah, hinter mir.
Ja, ja, es muss sein, ich halt das nicht aus.
Das klappt uns nicht.
Warum kann ich eigentlich nicht hier spawnen?
Wow, wow, wow, jetzt gibt es einen Downer.
Aber hauptsache eine halbe Stunde brauchen wir zum Raushöcken.
Wisst ihr, das war noch so in Zeiten bei Company 2, wo man einfach ohne Animation irgendwas machen konnte.
Aber aktuell muss ja hier wirklich überall so eine krasse Animation abgespielt werden.
Ja, ich bin da auch unschlüssig, ich muss ja sagen, mir hat die erste Alpha von Battlefield 5 überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Gar nicht.
Das ist so voll random, du weißt überhaupt nicht, wo was herkommt.
Aber das liegt einfach...
Guckt euch, das meine ich.
So the fuck, du hast überhaupt keine Ahnung, wo was ist.
So bam, einfach zack, du weißt überhaupt nicht, von wo.
Gespavent.
Reingesprayt in den...
Oder was ist das?
Hallo, hallo?
Treffen verboten.
Weg.
Man beschleunigt auch übelst langsam, guck mal, wenn ich jetzt hier...
Wenn du jetzt einen Gegner siehst und versuchst abzuhauen.
Da kannst du dich kaum umdrehen.
Gibt's was irgendwo? Spawn so?
So, gibt's irgendwas?
Okay, das STG 44, das war übelst OP das letzte Mal, kann ich mich dran erinnern.
Raus.
Ach, okay, eh, nicht leer Tasse.
Das ist nicht das letzte Mal, dass ich noch eine Tasse.
Ich weiß es immer.
Ich bin mir halt nicht sicher, ob das an dem Game liegt, dass ich das so irgendwie, dass du überhaupt keine Ahnung hast.
Also ob das generell an dem Game liegt, ob das an der Map liegt, ob das an dem Spielmodus liegt, oder ob das an dem Spielmodus plus der Map liegt.
Also, das kann ja alles sein, ne?
Und irgendwie fühle ich mich übelschwammig an.
Moment, Pleur? Motion Pleur?
Sekunde.
Das muss weg, deswegen sieht man auch nix.
Ähm, viel Luft für 70? Oh ja.
Machen wir mal einen Tick in Höhe, irgendwie 80.
Und, äh...
Wackel, machen wir mal weg.
Dann Krempel da weg.
Brauchen wir alles net.
Motion Pleur weg.
Was auch immer das ist, alles weg.
Ah.
Ich weiß zwar nicht, was ich jetzt alles abgeschaltet hab, aber abschalten ist immer gut.
Abschalten ist das Erste, was man in allen Games eigentlich machen muss.
Es ruckelt? Warum ruckelt das denn so?
Guck dich das mal an.
Voll inkonsistent, ja.
Alter, was ist das denn?
In den Settings ist noch mehr, okay, ja, mach ich gleich.
Das ist voll so Stellungsstells, das Game.
Da ist mit, da ist mit Flank-Action nicht viel.
Da oben ist einer.
Alter, was?
Also ich hab jetzt direkt vor mir Gegner, ich hab schon Gegner vor mir gesehen, aber auf einmal war er direkt vor mir.
Ich check das Game nicht. Ich hab echt Probleme so irgendwie zu verstehen, wo was passiert.
Spielst du auf eine Full HD? Ja, ja, ja.
Ja, ja, ich spiel 1080p.
Aber es läuft nicht gut. Ich glaub, man darf nicht vergessen.
Ich muss hier weg.
So, wo gehst du jetzt hier lang? Hier wirst du von den Gegnern gebashed.
Hier wirst du von den Gegnern gebashed.
Gibt's irgendwie die Option, nicht vom Gegner gebashed zu werden.
So, alternativ mal.
Vorne raus kann und man hört auch nichts.
Ah, vorbei.
Ja, was auch immer.
Am wenigsten stimmen die Settings jetzt halbwegs, nachdem wir die halbe Runde für gebraucht haben.
Also ich weiß nicht, ich hab im Rechner drin ein 8700k übertaktet auf 5GHz oder so und Multicore Enhancement an.
Also sprich, es laufen auch alle Kerne auf 5GHz, was übrigens lustig war, als es 37 Grad draußen war.
Da muss ich quasi die Klimaanlage fast anmachen, dass mein Rechner kühl bleibt.
Ja, ohne 1080 Ti. Also du kannst eigentlich gar nicht viel mehr Power im Desktop Rechner haben.
Aber das reicht, wenn es viel nicht.
Ja ja, 1080, es ist nur 1080.
Mal gucken, ob es eine neue Map gibt. Ich hab irgendwo gelesen, es gibt eine neue Map in dieser B.
Ich will keine Video. Ich will noch mal kurz in die Settings, ob man da noch ein bisschen mehr ausschalten kann.
Video, Advanced.
Frame Rate Limiter, also Limit.
Upscale Quality Settings.
Future Frame Rendering, was ist das?
Weil...
Ah ja.
Alles weg.
Ja Moment, heißt das jetzt... Moment, das verstehe ich nicht.
Heißt das jetzt, wenn ich das ausschalte, dann habe ich Raw Input?
Oder heißt das, wenn ich es anschalte, habe ich Raw Input?
So und wir stellen jetzt mal die Graphics auf Medium.
Wir stellen die Graphics auf Medium.
Post Processing Suck, das muss ein Schleck.
So, ist da noch irgendwie V-Sync an oder sowas?
Nee, es ist aus.
Wir lassen es mal auf 70, das war schon ganz okay.
Bei 70, 70 ist ja viel zu... 120, Foff, Eats.
Was steht nur auf 60 Hertz? Was? Was? Moment.
Was steht nur auf 60 Hertz?
Debated, warum? Alter, was ist das?
60? 2018, 60?
Was ist immer da hier?
Bin ich aber nicht gespawnt eben?
60.
Das ist wie 1996.
Moment, warum bin ich denn jetzt hier?
Okay, ich versuche jetzt mal da hoch zu...
Ja, Frames sehen deutlich besser aus, stabil.
Aber es passiert ja auch nicht viel.
Was? Alter, immer von der scheiß Seite, ey.
Du guckst hin, siehst Gegner oben, siehst Gegner unten und denkst,
ah, läuft sie von der Seite, bam in your face.
Immer.
Das Game ist wirklich in der Beziehung schlimmer als Kottel,
du bist dauerhaft von der Seite gebashed.
Obwohl du vorhin rechts geguckt hast und hast nichts gesehen.
Das riecht wie Morka Giga.
Und eins geht es mir immer noch so wie in der ersten Beta.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo ich hinlaufen soll.
Ich habe echt keine Ahnung, auf zur A hoch kannst du nicht?
Hier kannst du auch irgendwie nicht?
Wo kannst du? Wo kannst du überhaupt?
Wo kannst du überhaupt?
Und vor allem, warum kann das Messer kein Ding mehr kaputt machen?
Ist das die große Frage?
Ich weiß nicht, wohin soll.
Wo ist denn mein Team?
Wo sind denn die Leute?
Da ist einer, aber wo sind die denn alle?
Sag mal, kann das sein, dass überhaupt keiner da ist gerade?
So richtig?
Ist keiner da?
Ah, hier wird geschneibert.
Schneiber Action.
Okay.
Das heißt, ich verstehe, in dem Game steht man rum.
Und aimed.
Warum ist hier angeblich was?
Hä?
Was?
Ach nee, das war irgendein Map-Highlight oder so.
Gucken wir mal, ob wir da außen rumkommen.
Ist der Typ jetzt down gewesen?
Oh!
Wolltest du nicht regelmäßig YouTube bringen?
Hab ich ja auch Anfang, Ende letzten Jahres, Anfang des Jahres.
Nice Music, ja, das ist richtig schnaps.
Oh, hier ist der Anlocker.
Ich würde ultra gern ordentlich Bad Company 2 spielen.
Komm, springen, komm, springen.
Aber das Game ist halt, das ist halt vorbei.
Das macht Bock, also mir macht Bad Company 2,
ich ordne in Bad Company 2 fast mehr,
als in jedem anderen Battlefield.
Und vor allem noch kurzer Remo, geht das immer ganz gut.
Aber das ist halt vorbei, das Game.
Ich fände es ja nice, wenn mich ein neues Battlefield
wieder ein bisschen interessieren würde.
Sagen wir mal, Flank, Flank, Flank hat uns noch einer, oder?
Ist das richtig?
Wo flankt er denn?
Flank Action.
In your face.
Und was mir seit der ersten Beta, also nicht Beta,
ich vergesse einfach, was ich sage.
Ich meine seit der ersten Alpha von Battlefield 5.
Das erste, was mir negativ in dem Game aufgefallen ist,
dass das Voice Acting viel zu realistisch ist.
Ich finde, das brauche ich in dem Game Net.
Ich stelle es jetzt hoch zu dem Typ.
Also wisst ihr, was ich mit realistischem Voice Acting meine?
Also nicht, dass die Typen halt ordentlich reden oder so.
Das meine ich gar nicht.
Warum konnte ich den jetzt wieder durch den Baum stellen?
Weil ich checke dieses Game Net.
Das ist mir echt zu hoch.
Ich checke das gerne.
Das ist mir wirklich von dem, wo was ist und so.
Das ist viel zu undurchsichtig.
Overwatch.
Nein, Overwatch kann ich mir nicht mehr geben.
Das ist eh mein Problem aktuell.
Es gibt kaum Games, die ich spielen kann.
Weil entweder machen sie mir keinen Bock.
Gehen wir mal weiter hier.
Ich habe überhaupt keine Ahnung, wo ist denn hier überhaupt was?
Ich habe noch eins.
Das ist natürlich sehr, sehr nice.
Scheiße.
Popke.
Popke ist an sich, also ich finde, so als Außenbetracht.
Ich bin ja kein großer Battle Royale Fan.
Von Außenbetracht ist Popke das beste Battle Royale Game.
Okay, ich checke es net.
Wo geht man denn hin?
Und was geht eigentlich?
Oh, da ist der Panzmann am Start.
Ich finde übrigens auch toll, dass man bei seinem Panzer spawnen kann.
Und man nicht in das Auto reinkommt.
Voll im Kanton.
Kann man da jetzt noch rein oder nicht?
Das ist voll das Ding, achso.
Ich stelle es mal bei meinem Panzer rum.
Wow, da ist ein Gegner.
Alter, ist das Ding aus der Hüfte scheiße.
Da kriegste ja gar nichts.
Ich dachte, wir können jetzt eine Runde sprayen, aber nichts war es.
Sieht scheiße aus der Hüfte gewesen.
Ist das jetzt Zweiter Weltkrieg?
Ja.
Das ist Zweiter Weltkrieg.
Allerdings gebraucht er dies nicht.
Hallo? Treffen? Please?
Okay, der war eine hübsche Watschhäume.
Fuck, easy.
Da kommt noch nichts bei, was?
Bleibt mal hier liegen.
VW 2, genau.
Keiner ist auch hier gesagt.
Ach, ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe es ja schon in der ersten Beta Alpha hier gesagt.
Irgendwie fühlt sich das Game nicht gut an.
Ich kann es noch nicht so richtig erklären, aber irgendwie fühlt sich das nicht gut an.
Achtung, jebaited.
Wo sind denn die Gegner?
Hätte ja sein können.
Wir lassen erst mal die Typen vorlaufen und sich bashen lassen.
Was? Smoke? Ich will keinen Smoke.
Von allen Seiten? Ich meine, hallo?
Ich meine, die nennen wir es mal Front in Anführungsstrichen.
Die war jetzt ja eindeutig links auf dem Berg.
Aber nein, rechts hinter mir auf dem Berg sind auch Gegner.
Bitte die Musik nicht zu eintun.
Ohne die Musik dreh ich durch.
Ich hätte auch alternativ noch.
Moment.
Ich hätte auch alternativ noch hier.
Wir können auch Song of Storms 24 Stunden 7 hören, weil euch das lieber ist.
Oh, noch mehr Panzer.
Guck mal, warum kann man denn bei dem Typ spawnen?
Fuck, wir sind im Spawnen, warum sind hier Gegner?
Krabi-Musik ist das Beste. Es gibt nichts Besseres.
Ja, ich will keine Smoke übrigens.
What the fuck, von hinten? Hallo, das ist unser Spawn.
Kann man das customisieren?
Nein, das muss ich jetzt mal angucken.
Kann man customisieren, was man mitnimmt?
Wie gefällt der Battlefield 5 bis jetzt gar nicht?
Also ich habe ja schon die erste Beta, äh, Alpha.
Aber eh, das war das erste, was man spielen konnte.
Das hat mir auch schon nicht gefallen.
Also ich, ich, ich bin mir halt nicht sicher, ob das sich jetzt auf Map oder auf Spielmodus bezieht.
Der Mashed hat beispielsweise, äh, Conquest gespielt und das war ja aus seiner Sicht wohl ganz okay.
Kann man denn irgendwie Waffen customisieren? Kann ich jetzt irgendwie sagen, mach mal da mal was drauf oder so?
Nee, sieht nicht so aus.
Kann man hier die, die, die Granate vielleicht, kann man hier?
Nee, das ist ja langweilig.
Wieder nichts.
Der Mashed spielt Battlefield 1, das stimmt, der hat Übung.
Ja, ich gehe auch davon aus, wahrgenommen, ich meine, ich spiele aktuell mehr oder, mehr oder weniger gar nichts.
Ähm, ich gehe auch davon aus, wenn ich jetzt wirklich übrigens rein sucht würde, dann kommt man auch in dem Game wieder halt fix.
Zu Recht.
Aber es macht irgendwie so, von Anfang an...
Was?
Von wo?
Wir sind doch hier gerade gespawnt und hingelaufen, da kann doch von der Logik ja eigentlich gar nichts sein.
Die Fronten in den Games sind übelst?
Wir?
Die Fronten sind echt mega, mega...
Panzer.
Ja, theoretisch kannst du den Game gut aimen.
Durch, durch diese predictable Recoil-Geschichte.
Ich weiß nicht, wo ich hin soll.
Hier ist ein Gegner, da ist ein Gegner, hinter uns im Spawn ist ein Gegner, eigentlich ist überall ein Gegner.
Überall ein Gegner.
Also ich renne hier mit dem Spawn.
Ja, ja, natürlich, wo sonst.
Es sind überall Gegner, vergiss es.
Theoretisch müsstest du in dem Game eigentlich gut üben können zu aimen, durch diese Recoil-Geschichte.
Das Problem ist halt gar nicht mal, dass es so sehr... Also in Battlefield kommt es ja noch nie jetzt auf das Ultra-Super-Aiming an.
Wenn man sich den E-Hangs anguckt, das ist nicht schlecht, wenn man das kann.
Wenn man sich dann irgendwie einen M16-Gameplay von ihm angeguckt...
Was ist da oben?
Hängt da was in der Luft.
Hat mir ein paar Gameplays geschickt, wenn man aimen kann, ist es nicht verkehrt.
Aber Battlefield, weißt du, dieses Game wurde es auf das Ultra...
Das ist kein CS, ja.
Wo das auf das Ultra-Aim ankommt, sondern hauptsächlich eigentlich, dass du...
Gut, äh, gut...
Guck mal, warum ist hinter mir einer?
Warum?
Der ist links vor mir, der Gegner, warum sind zwei rechts hinter mir?
Ich verstehe das Game nicht.
Ja, er ist echt so...
Das ist die... Du hast es richtig erkannt.
Das ist die Krönung von chaotischem Gameplay.
Man weiß nichts, wo was ist, nichts.
Ich meine, das einzige, ich glaube, was wirklich geht, ist sich halt in so ein Häuschen hier zu setzen und zu warten.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es geht, also wenn man reinkommt, dann geht das echt halbwegs.
Ich meine, da oben sind 50.000 Gegner, was soll ich da jetzt machen?
Soll ich da jetzt durch den Bash hochrennen oder was?
In die Gegner rein?
Guck mal, von der Seite auch, das ist mir echt doof, ey, hallo.
What the fuck?
Ich meine, du blickst dir echt null durch.
Wie groß ist das Game?
Weiß man noch nicht.
Das ist noch closed, ja.
Guck mal, trennen sie alle links.
Von der Idee her kann, kann links, hier kann kein Gegner sein.
Das ist, nee, das ist sowas ähnliches wie Rush, das ist Grand Operation.
Guck mal, da kann kein Gegner sein.
Mein ganzes Team ist gerade den Weg lang gelaufen.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wo was ist.
Alter, das macht beschränkt das Game.
Den holen wir uns jetzt, ey.
360, down the hill.
Ich dachte irgendwie, da ist was, das haben wir nicht gesehen.
Was?
Wahrscheinlich kann man jetzt hier stehen.
Nee, wisst ihr was, Jungs, wisst ihr was wir machen?
Okay, dann nicht.
Ja, das war jetzt, das war im Weg, ich war verkackt.
Ich wollte jetzt so ruhig ins Haus setzen.
Einfach warten.
Also ich vermute, die SCG ist immer noch so Roll-Round mäßig mit das Beste.
Weil dieses kleine Ding ist auf Range halt kacke.
Oh, wir haben was eingenommen, guck dir das mal an.
Okay, ich bin mitten im Gegner drinne.
Ich sehe zwar nichts, aber passt schon.
Kann man noch im Gegner gucken?
Okay, was?
Was?
Und wo war das denn jetzt?
Warum ist Battlefield nicht mehr ein Uplay-Wett?
War Battlefield mal ein Uplay-Store?
Debated.
Da ist der Biergott.
Wir haben den Biergott geohren.
Ja, Eax, ich hätte wirklich, ich hätte mal die Cockpit erspielen sollen, das ist richtig.
No, no Cards.
Aber zumindest ist, wenn man auf dem absoluten High-End-Rechner das Grafik auf Mittel stellt und alles aus, dann läuft es gut.
Das ist schon mal schön.
Eax auch, Eax, er steht so aus.
Ah, das ist mal ein Squad.
Übrigens, ich muss euch gleich mal was zeigen.
Gestern habe ich eine Mail gekriegt.
Oder was ist gestern? Die Mail ist schon einen Monat her.
Aber ich habe sie gestern erst gesehen.
Spawn.
Ah, nicht genug Leute.
Ich habe gestern eine Mail gefunden, da hat mich eine Firma angeschrieben, die einen als Halbdeutsch-Fest, ich habe es ja schon auf Twitter geschrieben,
die einen Gaming-Desk, einen Gaming-Tisch produziert.
Das Ding sieht aus, ich kann euch das gleich mal zeigen.
Wollt ihr das sehen? Ich kann euch mal ein paar Bilder davon zeigen.
Das Ding sieht aus wie eine Mischung aus einem Alienware-Gehäuse plus irgendwie ein bisschen LED-Beleuchtung oder so.
Und also, ich muss jetzt ehrlich sagen, was ist eigentlich mit den Flugzeugen los?
Was genau geht mit den Flugzeugen da bitteschön ab?
Will das Flugzeug nicht vielleicht vorwärts fliegen, bevor ich da einsteige?
Jetzt hat es es geschafft, jetzt fliegt es vorwärts.
Gaming-Tisch, genau.
Immersion-Animation.
Ja, zumindest das Ding sah aus wie ein Alienware-Gehäuse, halt in Tischform.
Einfach mal Pufft, Pufft, Brotzeitleben weg durch Spawn.
Auch nice, nice Idee.
Weil es sah aus wie ein Alienware-Gehäuse, hatte irgendwie komische RGB-Beleuchtung,
und als man es sah, finde ich relativ...
Oh, das Haus ist Gameplay-technisch glaube ich enorm relevant.
Mit dem Schnee hier drinnen wird es schön ab.
Ich renne jetzt mal mit meinem Typ dahinter her.
Ich finde man muss kontrollierter schießen, in dem Game.
Aber das ist schon mal...
Da ist nicht so viel mit einfach sinnlos draufhalten.
Es sei denn, wenn das geiler Schneiper tut, dann ist das kein Problem.
Kann man das hier von der Seite reinwäschen?
Did, did, did, did, did.
Komm, jetzt wird es gebashed.
Geschreckt.
Ja guck mal, es kann von rechts nichts kommen, es kann nichts kommen, da ist nichts.
Außer an den Typ oben.
Hä?
Okay, rechts, rechts immer.
Also das ist wirklich, also Frontlines vergesst in dem Game.
Aber man kann in Feuermodus...
Wahrscheinlich V, oder?
Das ist die gleiche Map, ja.
Oh, oh, brets.
Jetzt in Feuermodus jetzt?
Ja, nice.
Sorry, was du fragen wolltest, ich hab's nicht gelesen.
Posten.
Alles über Angst.
Wo sind die Gegner?
Ach ja, das ist auf dem...
Oh, piss euch.
Und das auf dem Boden rumgerobbe, der Toten-Gegner ist auch mega verwirrend.
Was?
Was war das gerade?
Animation.
Ich check jetzt nicht wo Gegner sind.
Okay, also...
Wie siehst du nix?
Was ist das?
Macht keinen Bock.
Also was der Zorix hat gefragt, woran könnte es liegen, wenn man Upload zwar im Speedtest normal auszieht, aber sobald ich zum Beispiel einen Stream starte, nur durchschnittlich 3000 Kilowatts ankommt.
Wenn du viel uploadest, hast du automatisch weniger download.
Das ist normal.
Oder oben gedreht, ich mach den.
Aber das ist normal.
Das ist normal, also sprich, wenn du DSN am Schluss hast, also sprich...
Oder Kabel, reicht ja auch.
Also sprich...
Was?
Alter, das Game ist echt der Witz.
Ich bin da reingesportet, ich so hier...
Das ist ja mehr random als kop, ey.
Ja, also wenn du irgendeinen Mediaanschluss hast, wo du ja auch viel weniger upload als download hast, oder wenn du normalen DSN-Anschluss hast, ist das normal.
Dass wenn du viel uploadest, du auch weniger downloaden kannst.
Ich hör Piss-Piss-Piss hier jetzt.
Piss-Piss-Piss, Alter.
Hier ist es voraus.
Ah, Moment, Schuss-Modus, Schuss-Modus wechseln, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Okay, das funktioniert prinzipiell schon mal viel besser.
Wollt gern wissen, wo was ist.
Was?
Von wo denn schon wieder, Alter?
Du stirbst laufend in der Ecke.
Achso, es könnte sein, dass du eine kack Verbindung ebenst zu den Twitch-Servern hast, aber eigentlich...
Du probier doch mal einen anderen aus.
Du musst ja nicht unbedingt den Twitch-Server nehmen, weil die in der Nähe.
Du kannst ja auch irgendeinen anderen nehmen.
Kann man eigentlich Squad wechseln?
Squad-Item, beste, beste, beste Name für ein Squad.
Item, ich will zu Squad-Item, lass mich bitte in Squad-Item rein.
Squad-Easy ist auch nicht schlecht, Eats.
Hallo, warum kann ich da nicht rein?
Join.
Oh, das ist gelockt, sieht man das irgendwie?
Anscheinend nicht.
Geht nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Anscheinend geht das nicht.
Es ist ja normal, dass man in neuen Spielen, wenn man jetzt nicht gerade den Vorgänger durchgängig gesucht hat, sackt.
Das legt sich aber in der Regel relativ viel, wenn man Bock hat, das Spiel viel zu spielen.
Mein Problem ist, ich hab kein Bock an das Spiel zu spielen.
Ich hab wirklich überhaupt keinen Bock.
Ich hab mir extra einen Beta-Code besorgt, dass ich mir das angucken kann.
Dass sich da irgendwas geändert hat Gameplay technisch.
Es macht immer Spaß, Gegner zu killen.
Das heißt schon was.
Normalerweise macht Gegner killen in jedem Game Bock.
Mal gucken, ob das noch geht.
Oh fuck, das geht noch.
Verreckt, Alter.
Was soll das?
Schreckt.
Hüpf.
Okay, ich muss hier weg.
Ich bin hier voll auf Präsentier-Teller.
Wo sind die Gegner?
Die sind hier noch irgendwo gewesen.
Hüpf.
Alter, hüpf da drüber.
Ist doch nichts.
Kann man Flank-Action machen?
Kommt mir nicht hoch.
Ich bleib wirklich an allem hängen.
Oh guck mal, da liegt was.
Es liegt da.
Boah.
But why?
Moment, ich bin geschossen.
Bleibt mal kurz liegen.
Oder auch nicht, das waren drei Gegner.
Geduckt rennen ist gleich schnell wie normale Sprinten.
Wie duckt man sich eigentlich?
Jetzt muss ich mir mal angucken.
Geht aber rein.
Rein da.
Geht halt da rein.
Auch gut.
Bisher kann man keine Waffe anpassen.
Oder ich check nicht wie das...
Ach ja, Moment.
Es gab doch Killstreaks in dem Game.
Hab ich doch ganz vergessen.
Wie ging das noch mal?
V halten?
Nee.
Okay, das müssen wir mal gucken.
Wie war das mit den Killstreaks?
Hat das noch jemand in dem Kopf, wie man Killstreaks aktivieren konnte?
Übrigens, dass es Killstreaks gibt, ist halt auch schon der Witz, ne?
Wie ging das noch mal Killstreaks aktivieren?
Eax, hast du das zu?
C?
Hast du das zu?
Ah.
Rocket Stealth.
Okay.
Ja, ich hab zu wenig Pong gestimmt.
Wollen wir mal gucken, wie das ging.
Das ist das neu...
Ja, das ist quasi das neue Rush, nur dass es sich unrushiger spielt.
Wie ging das?
Ach so, das geht doch...
Da muss man da steuern und sprinten, gleichzeitig.
Alter, nee, nee, nee.
Jetzt muss ich umstellen auf Poggle.
Alter, was ist hier los?
Kannst du voll vergessen, ey.
Ich hab auch keine Ahnung, wo hier überhaupt was ist.
Okay, ich verpiss mich mal.
Hier kommt doch jetzt bestimmt von links gleich was.
Da war einer, wer hätte das gedacht.
Okay, Single-Schuss, größer, Autofire, das auf jeden Fall.
Man kann ja auch saumäßig schnell tappen, ne?
Das war Single-Schuss und dann kam einem vor wie Autofire.
Wo ist hier was?
Da gibt es doch keine Deckung so richtig, ne?
Killstreaks, ja.
Ja, warum auch immer.
Warum auch immer Killstreaks.
Man weiß es nicht.
Wow.
Was?
Ah, man kann...
Ah, verstehe, man kann das...
Man hat Dynamiken, kann das Zeug damit...
Müssen wir vielleicht mal die Fähigkeiten angucken.
Das wäre nicht schlecht, weil ich glaube, ich hab auch so was.
Oh, ein Sniper-Scope, eine rare Sniper ist am Start.
Übrigens, das ist das Schlimmste in dem Game, dass die noch rumkrabbeln.
Hallo?
Schreckt.
Boah, ich hab dich gerätzt, Kollege, ich hab dich gerätzt.
So, ich guck mal kurz in Chat, warum komm ich nicht in Chat rüber?
Was ist hier los?
Chat.
Okay, ich darf das nicht rüberbringen und auch nicht...
Ah, jetzt darf ich rüber, mit der Maus.
Lass schon alles einfach ausprobieren, dann ist das gleich, dann weiß ich auch nicht...
Das ist komisch.
Vielleicht, vielleicht bremst dein Provider irgendwie Streaming-Zeugs oder so, aber das
wäre eigentlich schon gelangt.
Warum?
So, dann stellen wir jetzt erstmal ein, dass man geduckt, dass man geduckt, immer geduckt
bleibt.
Dann kann man nämlich gesprintet, äh, sprinten im ducken, das ist besser, so.
Dann lass mich in die Settings, options, controls, holds, soldier, sprint, ne, ne, ich spiel
nicht, ich spiel nicht.
Seht ihr's irgendwo?
Wo ist crouch?
Crouch-Toggle gibt's, ne?
Ah, ach, X, das ist schon belegt, ein X, ein X, ein X, ein X, ein X, ein X, ein X,
ein X, ein X, ein X, ein X, ein X, ein X, ein X, ein X, ein X, ein X, ein X, ein
X, ein X, ein X, ein X, ein X, ein X, ein X, ein X, ein Xsch, eine Xsch, yolk, yolk,
Cron muss auf Maus 3. Unbedingt. Wichtig. Kann man dann hier den da machen und gleich
wieder mit Shift aufstellen. Wo wird hier was? Auch da oben stellt es was. Granate.
Wo ist der andere Typ? Hier war noch einer eben. Angeblich zumindest.
Nord-Nord-Map. War da noch einer. Da denke ich auch, the fuck. Wo war ich getroffen? Alter,
ich hänge an dieser verkackten Kiste ey. Hat mich wieder irgendwas vom Arsch der Welt
gehittert. Kommst du raus? Da ist er. Komm her.
Ich hab was hinter mir gehört. Moment, da ist doch was. Oben, oder? Ah, der ist down.
Tief. Na toll. Macht ihr Battle für 5 Spaß? Nee. War es nicht. Hatten wir aber die erste
Hälfte auch schon nicht. Likes eigentlich jetzt. Ich wurde gerade übelst geouten. Ich
weiß nicht genau von wo, aber ich wurde geouten. Also Singelschuss-STG ist auf jeden Fall besser
als Auto. Auto kannst du voll knicken. Auto triffst du nix. Singelschuss geht ganz gut.
Das bin ich ja nicht für die Klasse. Ah, ich hab hier auch. Ach, ich hab hier ne Panzervaus.
Guck mal da. Wie es mir vorkommt, dass ich schon in die Battlefield gespielt hab. Ist
aber echt so. Das kommt einem übertrieben komisch vor. Auch teilweise wenn man nur 2
Wochen nicht gespielt hat. Ich hab jetzt nicht ein paar Monate nicht gespielt richtig.
Bist du noch in der Nähe von Frankfurt? Ja. Bin ich noch. Wo gehts denn jetzt lang? Runterstelzen
das. Auto, kann man da rein? Jetzt bin ich mal einsteigend jetzt. Guck mal was beim B
Sturzes. Wobei ich glaub ich bin der Einzige der dahin geht. Mach den platt. Ey ne ey ey.
Ich frag mich ob ich jetzt geheiligt bin. Oder nicht. Wo sind die Gegner? Oh da sind
ganz viele Gegner auf der Brücke. Direkt alter.
Na gut, da. Mehr ging nicht. Äh, mehr ging nicht. Also Singletap STG44 ist auf jeden
Fall besser als Auto. Bist schon gehypt auf die neuen Videocard mal gucken. Also ich
mein die 1080Ti reicht mit Sicherheit noch ne ganze Weile. Sollte ich mal wieder ein
bisschen mehr machen hätte ich die Chance drauf wahrscheinlich auch was zu kriegen.
Aber so ich bin mir auch zu blöd da irgendwie zu nah. Also ich will jetzt da auch gar nicht
fragen weil ich mein ich mach nix. Wenn ich gar nix mache komm ich mir blöd vor wenn
ich sag ja ich mach nix aber ich hätt gerne Grafikkarte für 800 Euro oder wohl. Das ist
mir da ein bisschen blöd. Wo sieht man eigentlich wie weit die Runde ist? Ah jetzt haben wir
ne Minute Zeit für was auch immer. Für was haben wir jetzt ne Minute Zeit? Ah alles
zu basteln haben wir ne Minute Zeit. So nicht Kollege.
Wo stellst der hier nach?
Pantsman fahr vor. Oh voll in die Fresse ey.
Das Ding mit dem Scope beziehungsweise nicht mit dem Scope das Ding mit dem Red Todd oder
so was das wär nice. Weil du so mit dem Iron Sight auf die Entfernung hast ein bisschen
wie die Schmerzen auf die Gegner zu kommen.
Mensch jetzt noch das Gamer Klopapier damit ich klar alles auen. Aha von da. Ich dachte
das ist ein Flugzeug oder so. Ja das stimmt. Frazer LP auch diese in Kerschen Geschichte
das haben sie ja groß angekündigt. Ist wirklich was draus geworden ist der jetzt ne? Oder
ich hab einfach die Generalität von den Kerschen nicht kapiert. Wo gehts denn eigentlich lang?
Wo gehts denn eigentlich lang? Wo gehts denn eigentlich lang? Wo gehts denn eigentlich
lang? Wo gehts denn eigentlich lang? Wo gehts denn eigentlich lang? Wo gehts denn eigentlich
Canada
Wo wo ist dieses game
Was gläub auditionen mit drei influences glaube ich mich
glaube ich nicht, das ist zu kompliziert in deutschland
ja und im endeffekt gewinnen sie ja auch nichts großartig dadurch
also aus ihrer sicht, ich meine das würde das game ein bisschen authentischer machen
was es wahrscheinlich eh schon nicht wirklich ist
ich check das game, es ist von jeder seite, es ist irgendwas
ja richtig, das game ist mega unübersichtlich, extrem unübersichtlich
ich hätte ja gerne wieder einen battlefield, was mir übelst bock macht
wo ich dann einfach mal zwei wochen am stück mehr oder weniger spiele
und übelst mal wieder was wegbauen kann in einem battlefield
aber battlefield 3 war das letzte so richtig
ah battlefield 4 war auch ganz nice, in der richtung zumindest
was? warum schreit der typ? was hat den hier getroffen überhaupt?
heal please, alter heil dich doch mal
heal, come on, come on
bleib jetzt einfach hinter der ecke stehen
ok der heilt sich nicht
was, was, was, was tötet, was killt mich denn hier?
was?
kann mir einer erklären was mich da jetzt gerade gekillt hat?
feuer? was für ein feuer?
wo war da feuer?
da war kein feuer, jebaited mich halt, ne, ja das war ne sonne, das kann ne sonne nicht
gewesen sein
die kälte, genau
ok wir stellen uns jetzt zu b
kann man halt schonmal ein killstreak machen
ne, dafür zacke ich zu sehr
ja, besser, besser spot, hab ich schon gemerkt, am letzten mal
wenn die gegner da sind halt, das sind sie grad nicht da
ne, ach irgendwie, ich weiß nicht
what the fuck, what an idiot's game, das ist ran, das ist doch kein rush modus, rush heißt
klarer
das was rush am klarsten ausgezeichnet hat ist, ne klare frontlinie, wo was ist
deswegen war rush auch außer für heli stellste der krasseste bash modus aller zweiter
ich weiß überhaupt nicht wo ich hin soll
nix wie weg er
ey fliegen die loft
wo ist hier was?
wo stellste es hier?
nope
ah, ey gut, dann stellste wir mal zu a
mein problem ist, ich glaube die spawnen jetzt im rücken
ich hab das gefühl die spawnen uns im rücken jetzt, oder?
das würde voll zu dem game passen
das ist neuer, ja das ist operations, genau
es soll halt so der ersatz irgendwie für rush sein, weil es rush nicht gibt, aber es
spielt sich nicht mehr rush
richtiger rush modus
tja, wäre aber in den schnee gehüpft
hat aber kein bock drauf geacht
ne, rush, also das letzte was ich gelesen hab, gibt's kein rush
sei denn die haben da noch mal ne 180 grad wende gemacht, am anfang hieß es gibt kein
rush
wo es eigentlich bei mir schon instant aufgehört hat, da sprach aber auch das game
also ich würd mich freuen, würden sie jetzt doch rush machen
ganz ehrlich, ich würd mich echt freuen
ich hab auch keine ahnung von wo hier gegner kommen
aus dem rush mit kill sufs
die spawnen doch garantiert hier im rücken klein, wenn ich hier loslaufe
guck, der ist der erste schon, wie kommt er da hin?
ey ey ey, richtig ey ey, die emma maschinenpistole
ey, die emma maschinenpistole, die emma maschinenpistole
auf die range ist singelschuss dann doch nicht so der weis als letzter schluss
kein eigener rush, ja das ist total kacke, rush, beste
rush ist der beste spielwurz
auf, lass mich spawnen
ich glaube ich lege das wechseln auf die zweite maus-taste
also das schlussmodus wechseln
fuck alter
wo ist er?
warum kommt da jetzt ein dude von mir her?
aber eben noch gegner
battle royale, da bin ich ja mal wirklich gespannt drauf wie sie das machen
sowohl hier als auch im neuen kott
es ruckelt übrigens
by the way
by the way, by the way, es ruckelt
es ruckelt richtig
es ruckelt mit 70 fps
das ist für einer
stell dir mal einen tipp da hoch
wie komme ich, hier ist ja auch wirklich was wo man flanken kann
die spawnen doch hinter uns, ich sag es euch, die spawnen hinter uns
die spawnen hinter uns, warum spawnen hinter uns, ich verstehe das dann
wie ist denn, ich versuche jetzt ohne scheißdienel, ich versuche an die logik zu checken
warum spawnen hinter uns?
wo hier, also
sind wir im gegner spawn, der gegner in unserem spawn oder ist das spawn einfach im kreis
ich glaube wir sind im gegner spawn oder
wie kann das eigentlich sein, dass man das nicht offensichtlich checkt
warum kann man hier nicht durchschießen
alter, komm her
ich muss mal kurz hier campen bleiben
bis der trip sich geheilt hat
das ist
das ist ein bisschen das problem daran, wenn du gegner auf der erde rumkriechen hast, du weißt nicht wer lebt und wer jetzt nicht lebt
ich habe übrigens so nichts gegessen, ich bin heimkommen bestreben angemacht
so war es so
angemeldet
science klein müssen wir ASMR eating stream machen
oder das was wir zu fuddern wollen
ist hinter mir was?
lebt das?
das lebt mich
alter, ich dreh dich mal um
ja, da ist nichts reingegangen, ist klar, ist klar
man sieht ja auch nichts richtiges drin
schneestellz
was?
das ist so weird, das ist so weird, das ist so weird
das spiel ist so weird
der
ja, Mr. Milchmann
ich, ich
mit dieser ganzen battle royale geschichte
ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass der battle royale Hype abnimmt
und ich habe es ja am Anfang des Jahres gesagt, ich wette mit euch, wenn alle auf diesen Zug aufkriegen battle royale
dann ist battle royale wieder vorbei
also sprich, wenn die großen anfangen
oh, das ist ein tank
dann ist, dann ist wieder vorbei
oh, warte, ich habe doch hier einen pants man
ja, das ist ein bisschen, ein bisschen battle royale, so ein bisschen wie mit fidget spinner
als alle angefangen haben zu sagen, oh, wir sind jetzt richtig cool, wir machen jetzt fidget spinner giveaways
oh, wir machen jetzt fidget spinner damit und wir machen jetzt hier das und hier
und dann wollte eigentlich keiner mehr den fidget spinner haben
wisst ihr was ich meine?
so die, so die großen Marketing Läden, die sind einfach lahm, was sowas angeht
und das Problem, was du hast, ist halt, wenn du dann, wenn dann deine krassen Marketing Experten halt überhaupt nicht so
nicht so selbst drin sind
das hieße daran, wenn nichts quasi
nicht internetaffine Menschen versuchen Memebildchen zu kreieren
das klappt nicht, kennt ihr das?
wenn dann irgendwelche Leute, die halt überhaupt keine Ahnung davon haben
irgendwie versuchen irgendwelche Memes zu basteln
und dann zu posten auf ihren Social Media Plattform mit 500 Followern
und sich dann wundern, hm, warum interessiert das Ganze denn keinen
ja, sollte man sich vielleicht mal welche schnappen, die wissen, was sie machen
und selbst Ahnung davon haben, weil sie einfach irgendwie ja so mit dabei sind
ja
hinter mir, ist was?
angeblich
also, wie man wissen aus Skyrim, empfindlichste Sache, wo man einen killen kann, ist ja eindeutsch das Spiel
ich muss mal kurz ans Futter
hallo
ich will, ich will entweder das oder das
so, Kontrolle
ha, ich muss hier weg, wenn die mich sehen, bin ich am Arsch
ich bin ja nicht so der krasse Sniper, du, wie der Typ da hinten
stellst du lieber vom Berger
ich will den spotten, lass mich doch einfach spotten
was trifft mich hier denn?
was auch sonst, wie von der Seite
wo sieht es aus, Mr. Game Tester?
wo wir gerade bei Memes sind und Leute, die eigentlich keine Ahnung von
ja, Internet und
Dinge haben
aber, was sie gerne wollen
ich hab heute
bei mir in der Firma
was gesehen
wir haben jetzt so einen
warum verschwindet der Typ eigentlich im Boden?
warum ist der nicht tot?
ich erzähl dir gleich das, was ich erzählen wollte
hey, stirbt nichts
so, Achtung, krasser Flank
krasser Flank
nein
nein, fuck
ähm, zumindest ich hab heute bei mir in der Firma was entdeckt
da konnten quasi unsere Marketing-Menschen
können da ihre Ideen irgendwie reinschreiben
und da haben wir ein Radar für neue Trends, hab ich gesehen
da muss ich halt überlegen, das sind halt Leute, die das da reinschreiben
ja, ich hab überhaupt keine Ahnung, was sie reinschreiben
und was stand drinne?
Blockchain?
fuck, was zum Teufel
halt ohne wirkliche Beschreibung, einfach so random
so nach dem Motto Trends 2018, Blockchain
Blockchain ist die Antwort auf alles und was ist da heute Abend?
Blockchain
und wie war es heute auf der Abend?
ja, und wie ging es heute auf dem Klo?
Blockchain, Blockchain kannst du aktuell zu allem sagen
und solche Dinge haben wir da drin
ihr habt überhaupt keine Ahnung, was ihr da reinschreibt
aber hauptsächlich Blockchain
ja, ja Machine Learning stand auch drinne und solche Dinge
wo ich mir gedacht habe, ok, da ist irgendeiner von der Marketing-Abteilung hin
und hat sich mal so Best IT Buzzwords 2018 rausgesucht
und hat gedacht, boah, ich bin jetzt geil
und hat es mal reingepostet
und ich hab mir vorgenommen, morgen werde ich da auch noch ein paar Buzzwords reinschreiben
das Problem ist
ich hätte da sonst schon mit Buzzwords geflutet
aber wenn man das da einträgt, ist man standardmäßig als Pate für dieses Projekt
und ich will nicht Pate für irgendein komisches IT Buzzword sein
wo keiner außer ich in erinnern versteht, was damit gemeint ist
zumindest habe ich im Vorgehen, morgen trage ich mal eine Sache ein, um die Leute zu verwirren
ich werde morgen Progressive Web Apps eintragen
und dann erstmal Fragezeichen auslösen, wo ich alle denke
was ist das, was ist das, warum ist das ein Trend
was will der von uns, will er uns verarschen, will er uns debaten
dann wissen sie nicht, was, was, was sagt es
so und dann muss ich gucken, dass ich nicht als Pate drinstehe, weil da habe ich wirklich keinen Bock drauf
also am besten ist, ich würde, ich könnte mich quasi an einem Rechner von jemand anderem einloggen und das posten
Progressive Web Apps, ja, das ist, das ist sowas wo keiner so genau weiß, außer Google glaube ich
Hallo, ich bin raus
da kann ich raus
wo keiner außer Google so genau weiß, also Instant Apps ist auch sowas schönes
so genau weiß, was eigentlich Sache ist und warum man das überhaupt braucht, aber man braucht es anscheinend
also Progressive Web Apps sind quasi Web Apps, die man auf dem Handy mehr als Apps verwendet
oder quasi schon verwenden kann, bevor man sie aus dem App Store installiert hat
warum schießen wir unseren Spawn?
das ging auf Waldparaiso nicht, das war auch eine Schneeme, fällt mir nur gerade so als Vergleich an
kennt ihr noch Waldparaiso, nicht Waldparaiso, Port Valdas meine ich
kennt ihr noch Port Valdas, da ist man auch am Anfang runter gesprungen und da haben sie auch in die Luft geschossen
aber man konnte nicht in den Spawn schießen
und da hat man gemerkt, da hat sich irgendjemand was bei der Map gedacht
man merkt relativ einfach, ob sich einer was bei der Map gedacht hat
nämlich, ob man in den Spawn schießen kann oder nicht
es gab in Bad Company 2 auch viele Scheißwämpfe, wo man in den Spawn schießen konnte
aber erst, nachdem man quasi so dominiert hat, dass man jeder in den Spawn gedrückt hat
und nicht schon standardmäßig, dass man quasi von seiner Defense Position in den Spawn geguckt hat
wo gehts hier überhaupt lang?
und warum gehts hier?
also ich hab den Eindruck, da haben sie nicht wirklich was bei der Map gedacht
es wirkt sehr undurchdacht
oh NA-Aim des Todes ey
jetzt hab ich auch noch fettige Salami-Finger ey
ich bin da
so, erste Brötchen weg
aber ich hab barbische Finger
warte mal
da rutscht mal auf der Maus
weg
Lauf
achso, wir mussten das Ding in die Luft sprengen
Moment, der lebt noch? Der lebt noch?
der lebt noch?
ich war schon wieder auf dem nächsten Gegner drauf, weil ich dachte, der ist bestimmt halt down
hat er irgendwie 8 Schuss reingeballert
wo ist eigentlich mein Team?
da ist einer, zudem ist wer es
ich muss hier mal weg, ist mir zu viel Action
also ich mein eigentlich muss man jetzt hier mal gucken, weil hier kommt doch bestimmt gleich was, oder nicht?
oder doch? Warum ist es schwarz geworden jetzt?
das Spiel verwirrt mich unglaublich
ich bin ein Gegner
Medic Blitz
da kommt gleich von hinten was, warte mal, wie er fliegt
Hallo, sterben please
von wo?
da kommt doch gleich was von hinten
ich sag's euch leute, da kommt was von mir, stell's uns in den Baum
ich seh nix, ich seh nix, aber der sieht auch nix
oh hier stirbt alles, schlecht, ganz schlecht, weg hier
schiss dich, Max, hau ab
Max, hau ab
Schuss braucht er eigentlich
die Map ist richtig, vor allem Titan, die Map ist richtig confusing
ich blick auch nicht durch, wirklich nicht
wir machen jetzt mal Medic, nee wir machen das mal Angie
nee wir machen mal Medic, Medic mit mp40 haben wir schon, mal ausprobieren ob das Ding was taugt
oh oh ich lande grad in 30 Gegnern
über uns sind 50 Gegner oder so
was trifft mich, was trifft mich denn hier
ich kann mich, ich kann mich selber stellen
ist nicht tot, hier stirbt ja nix
das war einer
wo sind sie
es dauert auch nicht mehr lang bis die Gegner kommen
was, was, hä
was, also Leute manchmal versteh ichs nicht
da ist grad keiner gestorben und irgendwie der andere ist 3 Minuten später an einem Headshot gestorben
habt ihrs gesehen, ich hab nix gemacht, auf einmal Bling Headshot
aus dem nichts
das flutscht wieder
nee die kommt, was
jetzt ist er gestorben, jetzt ist er gestorben
habt ihr das gesehen, der ist ne halbe Minute später gestorben
WTF
was ist das
ich hab doch gesagt der ist down gewesen
WTF
smoke, nee smoke wollt ich jetzt nach dem Typ nicht werfen
smoke ist overrated
Ammo, Ammo please, Ammo, gib Ammo
da ist kein Ammo
ey gib, Moment, Moment, es kam in dem Game noch Munitionskisten
Munitionskisten
Munitionskisten, da oben ist bestimmt ne Munitionskiste
ist hier ne Munitionskiste
ich will doch nicht aufs Dach sagen, gehts dir noch gut
wo ist ne Munitionskiste, Munitionskiste
oh ne Munitionskiste
ist das ne Munitionskiste
ah da ist ne Munitionskiste
aber da können die Gegner von oben rein schießen, das ist kacke
Munition, Munition, ja nice
haste Monster hatte aber, nee, oder
doch, ich bin mir nicht sicher, es könnte sein, dass ich mir gekauft hab, weil ich mit dem Fabian spielen wollte
alter hüpft doch mal hoch
seid doch nicht immer so lahme Säcke
ich bin auch schon selbst eher lahm genug ey
aber sogar ich komm hier drüber
übrigens warten ist in dem Game das beste, musst einfach warten, dann rennt hier irgendwas ins Farbenkreuz
einfach warten, guck da kommt der nächste schon, der gewascht werden will
erst mal geilen Smokestells hingemacht
wozu auch immer der gut ist
ah, bam, geht doch da auf
ah Smoke, ey ich denk immer ich hab ne gute Nate, aber hab ich net
ich hab das Sucker Nate
erst mal hier drinnen sitzen bleiben
oh, hört ihr den unterschiedlichen Sound hier drinnen, das können sie, das können sie aber da ist
Soundstells können sie
auch guck mal hier 13-3, jetzt gehts aber, jetzt wird gerekt
massiv, massiv geschreckt wird hier
13-3, Poggers
Hardcore Poggers
nichts wie weg, ja das war ne gute Entscheidung
jetzt von oben stellen
Rektorino
warum ist der nicht gestorben, warum ist der nicht gestorben
der war, der war 1% und dann hab ich nochmal 3 Schüsse hinterher geschossen, ist nicht gestorben
habt ihr das gesehen
17-3, yeah
ja, 96 Damage und nach 96 Damage hab ich nochmal 3 Schüsse hinterher geschossen
aber ich weiß es nicht, aber versteht es nicht, also Spell Level 5, man kann das nicht verstehen
oh, oh, oh, oh, ah alter, jebaited, jebaited
natürlich von hinten, von wo auch sonst
irgendwie ist das Trommelmusik, ne das ist Musik, dass ich normal im Kopf bleibe bei dem Spielen
na, 8 zu 5 kannst du das sehen lassen
gleich mal schön Batman an
sogar, sogar ich weiß nicht, die Nichtdeutschen legen sich auf, dass die Deutschen nicht Deutsch reden
aber ich mein, wo bleibt da auch die Immersion
sogar, kennt ihr noch, kennt ihr noch die deutsche Multiplayer Ausgabe von in Quad 5
die haben wenigstens habe zu Deutsch geredet
ja, glaubst einfach, guck mal oben rechts
Eax, bist du noch da, hast du zufällig mal wieder Overwatch gespielt in letzter Zeit
ok, ich glaube so langsam checke ich den Spielmodus
das hier ist immer die zweite Runde mit den Häusern
die erste Runde ist das, wo es als Attacker so ultra beschissen sich spielt
die zweite Runde ist das mit den Häusern hinten
wo es sich als Attacker auch am Anfang zumindest ultra beschissen spielt
und die dritte Runde ist dann Spawn Stealth bei den Gegnern
oder habe ich das richtig verstanden?
die nächste Runde ist Spawn Stealth in den Gegnern drinnen
man immer denkt, sie spawnen einem im Rücken
ey, das war meiner
Piss dich
FAQ Board
äh, ich hab Schiss
wo kann ich denn hin?
schmeißen wir mal was
ich bin der Medic, ich kann mir ja selbst was schmeißen
oh ja, ein Panzer macht das
ah, stürmen, stürmen, ran stürmen, bastion, bastion, bastion, bastion ins Haus bastion
oh fuck
keine so gute Idee
ich wollte einfach nur wissen, wie sie spielt gerade
und wie der neue Held so ist
der Ball, der Kreisel, der Kreisel, im Kreis, Ball, Kreisler
weiß gar nicht, Hammond, genau
aber Hammond heißt ja nicht Hammond in Game, er heißt ja irgendwie anders
rekt
die Klassen sind immer noch so, was ich bis jetzt noch nicht gesehen habe ist diese
diese Flair, Flair Spammerei
die ist mir noch nicht so aufgefallen
aber Overwatch ist auch so view only Game mittlerweile
ich gucke ja immer noch relativ viel, ich hab beispielsweise das letzte Apex Contenders geguckt
Runaway gegen
frag mich nicht
ist übelst mitgefiebert wieder, aber
Overwatch ist für mich so, so, so
view only, ich kann, ich halte es nicht aus zu spielen, aber ich gucke es gerne
weil halt, weil halt in den Pro-Matches Overwatch so gespielt wird, wie es gedacht ist
oh da ist einer
Alter, ich will dich retzen
also wir machen jetzt Stelzer, Stelzer extra hier unten rum
komm wir stellzen uns jetzt ganz hier unten am Arsch der Welt rum
und dann verrecken wir wahrscheinlich nach unserem geilen Flank
Leute hier ist nichts mehr, warum ist hier nichts mehr
und ich weiß nicht immer wo die Gegner her kommen
wo kommen die Gegner her
bestimmt in den Rücken, die schießen bestimmt in den Rücken die Gegner
ja Kollege
da hast du nicht mit gerechnet
da magst du dich jetzt von hinten weg basht
das hast du dir nicht so gedacht
dann du auch nicht
das habt ihr euch alle nicht so gedacht
oh da kommt noch was
sind die über mir
wo ist hier was
ich stelle sich mal um die Ecke
ich weiß halt nicht, kommen die von oben, kommen die von unten
da war doch noch einer, ist der runter gefallen
ich glaube der ist runter gefallen
oder auch nicht
von wo, von wo, von wo
ich muss mal um die Ecke
ok ich glaube jetzt kommt nichts mehr
wie lange ist die Alpha noch aktiv, ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung
unten oder unten
sehe ich das richtig
nicht hüpfen
nicht hüpfen ey
bin ich das
ist über mir einer die laufen gerade oder war das der Sound von mir
ne das war der Sound von mir
25, jetzt gehts aufwärts langsam Leute
also ich sehe schon wie man das in dem Game machen muss
man läuft einfach immer an einer Stelle im Kreis
und wenn was kommt wird er gebasht
guck easy, easy win
also dafür spiele ich schon zu lange schuld dass sowas klappt
das war der altbekannte wegrenn turn on fake
fehlt bloß noch in Kombination mit dem 360 Claymore Switch
da ist MLG Montage angesagt
manchmal laber ich ganz schön Blödsinn oder
richtig zusammenhangloser Crap den ich manchmal erzähle
richtig zusammenhangloser Crap
oh ich hab keine Munition mehr
manchmal lol
ich finde das kommt nicht oft vor
richtig skilliges Gameplay was man hier zieht
ich laufe immer an der gleichen Ecke lang
und mach sonst nichts ab und zu kill ich mal einen
aber man weiß ja auch nicht wo die Jäger sind was willst du machen
von wo
ich weiß nicht von wo
ich geh jetzt mal ein Stückchen vor
hier ist gar nichts mehr die Jäger sind jetzt eins weiter
wir haben es schon längst eingenommen
aber ich renn immer noch
wird das Gameplay auf den German Taters hochgeladen
ja
richtig erkannt
1st Battlefield 5 German Tater Montage
ich hab Schiss hier alleine
oh guck mal da unten stellst du was
unter uns, unter uns ist Stelz
Stelz-Action angesagt
hallo lass mich
alter ich steck fest
nee oder
ich steck
ich steck fest
DICE PLEASE
come on bra
ok jetzt gehts wieder
ganz toll, ganz toll
ok
oh ich hab das Meme Board aus
verdammt
ich wollte es jetzt eigentlich hier
in Confused einblenden
ich wusste das ich was vergessen hab
ich hab das Meme Board vergessen
alter kannst du noch sterben
nee aber ich
also Leute hat mich gebrüllt
und ich muss was futtern
aber ich hab außer was kleines
damit da noch nichts gefruttert
oh
wo geht hier was
es schießt mal einfach um
so easy
das Skamast
hat er gerade gesagt
Smoke Grenade Skamast
hab ich verstanden
was machen wir jetzt
ist das Spawn Campen
was wir hier machen
nee oder
das ist sinnlos Campen
was wir hier machen
nicht mal Spawn Campen
das ist gar nichts das ist
ich werde für 5 Minuten spielen
immer von der Seite
ok Bastion alter Bastion
direkt
ich bleib mal kurz liegen
ich hab Schützen
ok dann Chat noch
schreibt grad keiner was
das Rätseln dauert auch so lang
ich seh es jetzt schon kommen ey
keine Rätsel in dem Game
weil du direkt in Gefahr läufst
selbst gebashed zu werden
ich krieg kaum Ehe von hinten jetzt
was
Hahaha
Andiversum
nee nee nee
so ist es ja nicht
was kleines am Mittag
nee ich hab ein
ähm
ich glaub Roast Beef war es
Roast Beef hab ich gegessen
allerdings ein kleines
ein wirklich kleines ja
Roast Beefchen war das
das war kein ausgewachsenes
Roast Beef
das Rätsel in Battlefield 3 war
am geilsten
und Bad Company 2
Bad Company 2 war noch
übertriebener
er konnte sich durch die Wand
rätseln
kannst du noch jemand dran
erinnern
Bad Company 2 durch die Wand
rätseln
das war best dieser Arschweiß
auf
der ist direkt vor mir
ich schnuppe er
ich hab es nicht gecheckt
bis es ein Gegner ist
jetzt brechen alles ohne mich
ich bin verwirrt
das sind Gegner
und instant down
von anderer Seite
typisch Battlefield 5
würd ich mal sagen
ist das
das ist
Los Alpha
hier oben rechts
aber 34 11
jetzt gehts ja so langsam
warum kann ich eigentlich
mit meinem Squad spawnen
overrated
Teamplay komplett overrated
Squad spawnen
brauchen wir nicht
ich find es ein bisschen blöd
dass es nicht am Wochenende läuft
übrigens
ich hab jetzt gar nicht so
ich hab jetzt gar nicht so richtig
Zeit gerade zu spielen
warte mal
was wollte ich inlegen
ich wollte meinen Medic
auf
also sprich
ach nee
ich wurd gerätzt
ok gleich
wo ist hier was
das ist so wir das Spiel
das ist so wir
ok
das heißt ein Panzer
oder irgendwie sowas
warum ist es
ich frag nicht warum
die hinter uns sind
oder
es ist die fault
in dem Spiel
dass die Gegner hinter einem sind
zockst du eigentlich
noch
was trifft mich hier
meine Ecke
meine rumliegende Ecke
ich denke das ist die Ecke
oh nächstes Objektiv
nächstes Objektiv
oben war da was
da war da was
nee da war nix
das war einfach nur
map markiert
hinter dem Streamtitel
fehlt ein LoL
das ist richtig
ich hab das aber auch
weggelassen
absichtlich
dass mich Leute
darauf hinweisen können
das ist viel jetzt wichtig
aber das ist recht
da müsste eigentlich auch ein LoL
hin
wobei eigentlich musst du
oh fuck
wie siehts eigentlich vom Killstreak aus
haben wir mal langsam
einen Killstreak am Start
oh jetzt
jetzt
leiser jetzt
ah da ist ein Panzer
direkt vorder Nas
ich kann nicht vorwärts laufen
ich will mich da hinstellen
an jeder Ecke in diesem Game
an jeder Ecke
ich bleib jetzt hier liegen
sobald mir was reinkommt
bitte gebasht
da ist schon einer
vor mir
so ein Panzer
ja schaut euch rein Jungs
gönnt euch
wo ist hier was
ich muss weg
was genau hat mich jetzt wieder getötet
ich verstehs in dem Spiel
das ist einfach so
also wenn Panzer auf das Haus schießen
das explodiert nicht
ja das versteh ich
aber eben war nix
und einfach
wieder Feuer
das kann doch nicht in den Ernst sein
soll man in das Haus nicht rein
oder was
ich mein das Feuer ist schuld
ja
ich mein du stirbst an jedem Scheiß
du stirbst an treten
an Feuer
du kannst nicht
über kleine
Hügel hier richtig
drüberspringen
da ist ein Baro
ist auch da moin
da oben
schreckt
ich wollte einfach mal in die Richtung schießen
nicht dass ich was treffe
das ging natürlich nicht
ich muss mich ja verbluten lassen
dass ich schneller respawn kann
nice
oh ich dachte ich bin gerettet worden
Spawn
warum dauert das jetzt 5 Stunden ey
okay das ist wieder Gegner Spawn in uns drin
glaube ich
ja das ist wieder die Stelle wo die Gegner direkt bei uns im Rücken spawnen
guck da ist er schon
da ist er schon
nice
please
wer hat sich das ausgedacht
wir müssen hier und hier capturen
also wir müssen von hier nach da gucken und die Gegner spawnen
da
nice
what the fuck
was ist das
warum spawnen der Gegner im Rücken
warum ist das das default spawnpoint auf dieser Map
guck mal
wir müssen das capturen und müssen da
warum spawnen der Gegner
da
was ist das für ein Map Design
warum spawn der Typ da
so
genug aufgeregt
du weißt guck mal du hast keine Ahnung wo die sind die können von da sein die können
aber auch direkt hinter dir spawnen
yeah
geile Idee
hast du noch einen Alpha Key
nee ich hatte selbst nur einen
den habe ich überwischt gebracht
hätte ich den Alpha Key hätte ich da schon irgendwas gesagt
ich habe ihr gefragt
die Punkte sind das meine Punkte oder sind das Scott Punkte
nee Sebaro das wüssten sie wahrscheinlich nicht
aber mp40 gefällt mir
so ich muss jetzt midi pack unter Maustaste legen
midi pack war
ja 4
sehe ichs noch nicht
wo belegt
ach man kann ja nicht scrollen
man kann ja mit dem Mausrad nicht scrollen
das wäre ja was man mit dem Mausrad scrollen könnte
kann ich denn umschalten zwischen meinen Fisch
was ist das für ein Menü
Alter da ist es doch
na nice
also hier haben wir midi pack und hier haben wir hinlegt so muss es sein
kann ich so ordentlich spielen
können euch noch dran erinnern wo sie mich das letzte Mal autobalanced haben auf dem Server
und ich auf einmal quasi dein Gegner war in den mitten von eigenen Teammates
wisst ihr das noch
da bin ich nämlich hier gesportet als Gegner und direkt in den eigenen Teammates
also in den Gegner Teammates ja
au
weg
geh weg
das Lick Emote hat es euch angetan
spring
Flank Reno machen wir jetzt Flank Action
guck mal da ohne Wetter ohne Wetter schon rumgeballert
das ist guck mal Leute jetzt mal ohne keine Ahnung ist jetzt verreckt ich muss euch das jetzt zeigen
guckt euch das mal an das ist so kacke wenn als sieht man es nicht der Typ ist down wahrscheinlich was einer von mir
es ist so kacke wenn Gegner auf dem Boden sich noch bewegen und man denkt da krabbelt einer
wer kommt auf die unglaublich bescheuerte Idee das muss ich jetzt mal so sagen
dass ein Gegner der down ist aussieht wie ein Gegner der krabbelt
warum warum
warum
ich meine der ist down der sollte aus dem Game sein
den sollen sie ausplämmen oder so für mich die sollen einfach ausplämmen
einfach ausplämmen für mich die können ihn ja für die eigenen Teammates noch da lassen wenn es sein muss
meinetwegen aber die sollen für mich ausplämmen
alter fick dieses kacke ich kipps immer von der Seite
oh ich werd gerätzt der mit der Sniper tut der mich gerätzt
hüpf
nein nein nein
ich wollte nen retzen
das ist verkackt
das ist auch ein Problem dass man nicht mal schnell retzen kann ich meine ich hatte jetzt die Wahl quasi den Typ zu retzen
und sicher zu sterben irgendwie ohne ihn liegen zu lassen was ja eigentlich für beide Seiten keinen Spaß macht
für mein Teamate macht keinen Spaß dass ich ihn nicht retzen kann für mich macht keinen Spaß dass ich den Pfeil von der Flange sich verliere
äh Moment
hüpffeuer in 2k 18
ja das frage ich mich auch warum warum funktionierende Dinge aus alten Spielen übernehmen
es ist ja nicht so als das hat mich nicht getötet gut ich weiß gar nicht was es war aber es hat mich es hat mich nur es hat mich es wirft mich nur quer über die
aber das bringt mir nicht um ganz mit leben und da kommt ich bin als krasse Elite Soldat komm ich da drüber
das feuer ist schuld
da war er ich hab ihn gesehen
da war er
kleine stellzer wo ist er
da ist einer ich seh
hier können wir nicht weiter kommen auf den Sack
ich muss mir retzen
ich bin ja immerhin Medik
so jetzt können wir ein bisschen ran pushen
ok auf diese Range ist die Waffe nicht gedacht
Piss dich
Körbimusik am Start ja nicht muss so sein
oh es wird gerätzt
was zum Teufel ist das Game
es ist so wir es ist so wir
komm her alter komm her
ich hab doch gar nichts gemacht
wo spielt die Map ab was weiß ich
was weiß ich wo die Map spielt keine Ahnung
na mal auch mal sagen wahrscheinlich Skandinavien oder so wie es aussieht und Tannenwald Schnee
und bunte Häuser
Tannenwald Schnee bunte Häuser Solarlichter
Nordlichter Polarichter
das kann ja eigentlich nur Skandinavien sein oder Island oder so
aber ich glaube Island hat kein Wald richtig
Geografien 2018
ich schreib einfach mal No ich hab keine Ahnung was geht
ich warte ja noch auf die Frankfurt Map so wie das Teddy Teddy
schreibt
es soll noch ein EZB
aber dann vom Südbahnhof aus
aber ich stell mir das echt geil vor die Strecke
vom Südbahnhof in die Innenstadt zur Bank
man muss halt man muss die die Realität nicht so eng nehmen die EZB ist nicht mehr in der Innenstadt
aber die alte EZB war direkt in der Innenstadt
aber der Weg vom Südbahnhof über die Brücke das wäre eine übelst geile Battlefield Map
und auch die Kulisse in Frankfurt macht auch was her
hast du im Hintergrund hast du vorne den Main hast du die Brücke hast du Hochhäuser im Hintergrund
fast schon wie Siege of Shanghai
bloß nicht ganz so viele Hochhäuser
was war das? Schwerben?
smoke smoke so räudig
ich geh da jetzt rein und wäscht den Dude aber der ist schon tot
wir bleiben mal kurz hier drinnen stehen man weiß wann weiß ja nie so genau
ok da hab ich keine Chance mit meiner Kacke als Entschieda gegen
direkt alter weggefisst
jetzt mal so deutlich auszudrücken
Montage, ja macht Montage! Braucht best best of stream Montage brauchen wir jetzt
direkt as fuck war das
ich brauche Muni
wo ist der nächste Muni Laden
am Strand ist eine Munitionskiste
aber da kann ich nicht runter wenn ich da runter gehe bin ich am Arsch
wenn ich schon ne Weile so rum mach dann bin ich eh da
hier war doch ne Munitionskiste wo ist die denn
ok jetzt hab ich wieder Munition auch gut
es wird mal was ausprobieren ob ich hier reinkriechen kann für mehr Immersion
jawoll oh bester Spot
warum machst du eigentlich Low Latents äh nicht Low Latents ich weiß gar nicht wo das geht
bin Noob
aber so viele Latents ist doch gar nicht oder ich würd mal sagen so 10 Sekunden
und mit HLS Streaming ist auch schwierig viel weniger zu kriegen
äh wo sind Gegner? Gegner? aus dem Fenster hüpfen YOLO
und und ich bin nicht runter gelaufen das war die komplette Animation gerade
oh da ist ein Pantsman Pantsman brauchen wir jetzt
kann das was das Ding?
das ist ja räudig was das?
taugt das was?
ne das taugt nix
wobei wir fahren uns das Ding jetzt einfach mal ran
und hier oben in der Mitte ist auch noch ne Maschine
äh hallo Animation please Animation
was was da kaputt da ist
oh da ficken wir jetzt von der Seite rein aber richtig krass
und der Typ wird auch noch gerätzt warum steht der auf? Alter steht nicht auf bleib liegen ey
warum steht der auf um den zu retten? was soll denn das Scheiß?
der Lee ist müde
das war übrigens Absicht dass ich hier dran, dass ich mich selbst eins smoke
ich smoke mich absichtlich nochmal selbst ein
noch mal retz retz retz retz
noch mehr retz oh jetzt geht er ab hier der krasse Medic
der krasse Medic stellt so
sag mal hat er mich gerade eingesmoked?
ich hab ihn gesehen der mich auch
die Waffe ist scheiße
ah Kollege Spawn jawoll jawoll
5 4 auf lass mich spawnen du wartest ja in dem Game ewig bis du spawnen darfst
oh geschneibert fuck ich wollt mich gerade hinlegen scheiße
schreckt vielleicht retzt mich hier einer
ist hier einer
da ist keiner der Typ liegt auch da
oh nein ich retz
krasser Retzer
okay das ist eine mega scheiß Pose hier schau mal ab
richtig krass Pose ich geh mal oben zu den Häusern
und selbst wenn es einfach die Gegner ein bisschen unten weglockt so wirklich hinkommt tut man da nicht
aber steht da oben auch ein Tank?
was sind das für Gegner gerade
direkt
der könnte sich übrigens auch direkt selbst heilen anstatt dass man dann auch 3 Meter zu diesem Pack vorgrabbeln muss
jetzt läufts
wow das war aber auch mehr Glück als verstand jetzt
weiter gehts
da oben hängt einer in der Wand
Achtung wir machen jetzt einen Trick
wo ist er hin?
hä? wo ist der Gegner hin?
ist er down?
wo krieg ich denn durch
Flanken stells
so ein Ding war ich noch nie drinne in der Regel ist man da instant down
was das für ne Waffe
okay dann ist er instant down
wirst denn er
also muss sagen medic mp40 gefällt mir bis da echt gut
da geht was
naja gut nach alter battlefield 5 Tradition Gegner von der Seite
nein alter was
warum ist er da hochgekrabbelt ich wollte da doch gar nicht hoch
kackding ich wollte meinen mini pack aufheben warum krabbelt er aufs Dach
aufs Dach die beschissenste Position von allen
vor allem in der ewig Animation
wie ist der Schneidbach stells ab bis jetzt gehts eigentlich
also das Game basiert einfach drauf dass von allen Seiten Gegner kommen
ich würd gern hier unten spawnen
gibts aber nicht
dann kann ich vielleicht doch mal den dude spawnen
okay jetzt machen wir mega flank action
flank action auf doom
hauptsache mein Typ schreit mach ichs vorbei
ist die closed alpha ja siehe oben rechts
aber mittlerweile gehts halt aber hier guckt es euch an
der siebener ping ist am start
oh nein der achter ping
der achter ping
ich bin wenn jetzt kann ich einfach gerennen
ping ist getroppt von 7 auf 8
da sind dann die full immersive
ich sag jetzt nichts
ich sag nichts
steht der Server im Keller ja ich hab doch schon ein Video über den Server gemacht
natürlich läuft da auch Battlefield 5 drauf auf dem Server
ich hab meine eigenen Battlefield 5 Server hier stehen
zwei Meter hinter mir
deswegen hab ich auch ein siebener ping wie soll das sonst gehen
ich glaub wieder medic
übrigens guckt euch mal die Flugzeuge am Anfang an was machen die da
ich sehe leider nicht was ich accepten soll was soll ich accepten
ja ich würd's accepten ich sehs nicht
ich konnts leider nicht lesen was ich accepte
wartest du vorhin das anfrage oder was war das was war das grad da oben konntet ihr das erkennen
das sieht fast aus wie Captain Price da hinten links
es ist einfach erstklassiges geiles Design
dass man direkt in den Spawn der Attacker nach einer Sekunde vom Rundenbeginn schießen kann
super Design das beste Dice geilste was ihr je gemacht habt
das ist so fail
ich hab nen Typen wiederbelebt der mit dem Fallschirm verreckt ist beim Abspringen
was auch immer gemacht hat ja aber die Gegner können direkt reinschießen direkt
ich hab ne Donation gecheckt soll ich kann halt nicht gucken
aber danke für die Donation ich weiß leider nicht wer was wie wo wann
und ich hoffe ich denk nach der Runde dran zu gucken
ich muss nämlich am zweiten Monitor das dann Steamlabs rein
aber danke schonmal für die Donation
ich hab was getroffen
einfach so random random random Shot
oh jetzt die mega Flank Action am Start hier
Flankerino
da war noch was oder
der MJ Nutter war das
ok das war jetzt ein bisschen doof ich war ja mit dem Gegner
ok ich muss jetzt zur Donation gucken
das ist Baro seh ich das richtig das ist Baro wieder nice
das Archiv ist Baro macht ihr macht ihr keine Gedanken wegen dem Archiv
ich kann nicht laufen ich kann nicht laufen
jetzt bin ich da
geht das Game bei euch seht ihr was
P5 ist kacke bester Name
wer in letzter Runde mal unsere Killstreaks einsetzen kann
ich komme immer noch nicht drüber hinweg dass es wirklich Killstreaks gibt in dem Spiel
da guckt euch an Killstreaks
warum gibt es Killstreaks
ach du meinst Proxy LP das ist für die Immersion dass ich nicht laufen kann
ach so ist das ja dann ist das natürlich ok
für die Immersion
für die Immersion ist das alles kein Problem
warum wird das schwarz zwischendurch
ist von Elortrix programmiert oder was
warum wird es weiß und warum haben wir jetzt gefunden
ich blick nicht durch
das Game verwirrt mich einfach nur
ah der tiefe Schnee ist die Immersion jetzt verstehe ich ok nur das leuchtet ein
ne alpha Schusslick ein zwanzig
wobei man weiß eh nicht so genau was bei dem da da unterschied ist
aber ich sage schon mal danke für die ganzen Follows
ich kann jetzt gar nicht reingucken
was bringen wir eigentlich Level bei den Waffen
das ist auch toll dass der Chat da drüber ist
was war das dann
Achtung wieder Flank Action damit haben wir gute Erfahrungen gemacht
oh diese Runde war aber nicht so geil
aber letzte Runde ging übelst ab da
Achtung
da oben war einer
30 Milliarden Gegner um einen drum herum
und wie ist Battlefield 5 ich war es nett
letzte Runde haben wir wirklich ordentlich gebashed
da kann man nichts sagen da habe ich aber nicht auf Spawn gedrückt gerade
also letzte Runde habe ich doch niemals rufgeklickt
also letzte Runde haben wir wirklich massiv gebashed
und das hat schon irgendwo bock gemacht aber jedes Game
ich sage euch jetzt mal wie es ist jedes Game macht Spaß wenn du Gegner zerstörst
das ist einfach so die Sache ist die
man erkennt die Games die wirklich gut sind auch unter anderem daran
dass sie trotzdem das man auf den Sack kriegt
noch erträglich sind
so und das ist das Game nicht bis jetzt nicht
aber gerade ist wieder auf den Sack kriegen angesagt
auf den Sack kriegen time
letzte Runde irgendwie 38 noch was BÄM diese Runde SACK
vielleicht soll ich lieber mal oben lang
ja ich stelle sie mal oben lang
Musik ist beste
kommt doch jetzt bestimmt jeder Typ
Alter überall ist ein scheiß Gegner
ganz im Game nichts flanken
mal einsmoken dann gehts weiter
mal einsmoken
komm her ich seh nichts
warum war da noch einer
ich verpiss mich
ich kann euch nicht retzen
dich kann ich vielleicht retzen
vielleicht wenn ich Glück hab
Alter beweg dich wer hat sich dieses beschissene Wiederbelebsystem ausgedacht
was ist das denn du bist 10 Sekunden gestunt wenn du ein Teamate beleben willst
was ist das für eine Scheiße ey
ah riecht mich das auf
dann siehst du erst mal eine halbe Stunde nichts dann wieder beleben
ich brauch Muni
nooo Kollege soll nicht
so ich will es jetzt aufheben
wo wo ist man sieht man sieht man nicht mehr die Waffe
aber das Spiel ist auch so viel Leben ein Fail ey
was machst du da eigentlich Kollege
ich mach jetzt mal mit
die freudigste Waffe die es im zweiten Weltkrieg je gegeben hat
so jetzt kann ich nichts machen außer hier rum campen bis ein Gegner mir in die Arme läuft
gehts hier irgendwo ne Treppe rauf
soll hier nicht ne Treppe sein
Treppe outdated
permanent
ich kann nicht leider nicht wieder beleben ich bin kein Medik
wo sind Gegner
guck mal warum sieht es aus als kriecht der Gegner dabei ist er down
ich kann euch nicht wieder beleben ich hab nichts
ich hab keine Ahnung wo geht das her wirklich nicht
ich checks dann
da fährt ein Auto lang
ok ich hab keine Ahnung was da
ist da einer drin ich weiß nicht
ich mach spawnpoint geben
der sah so unübersichtlich aus
jetzt jetzt von hinten was natürlich
was zum teufel wo ist denn hier was so unübersichtlich
so unübersichtlich
doch es kann jeder wieder beleben
ok
natürlich wollte man haustipp ich muss weg
ich hab nur noch drei leben das ist doof
um nicht zu sagen das zackt
wir habens nice wir habens easy clap
unübersichtlich als battlefield 1 ich kann zu battlefield 1 nichts sagen
ich hab battlefield 1 nicht gespielt
battlefield 1 hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen das hab ich immer gar nicht geholt
der meister hat es mir letztens gegiftet
für die collection hat er gesagt
aber ich glaub nicht das spiele also battlefield 1 hab ich keinen vergleich
battlefield 4 ist so ein weltenkontrollierter
da war noch was oder
wow
wo ist er denn
ich hänge
wo ist eigentlich mein lebensanzeige hin
war das grad nichts zu erkennen
wo sitzt der denn im scheiß haus von
battlefield 3 sieht doch richtig gut aus
vor allem battlefield 3 flutsch wie eine eins ja
für die optik
oh ey bei dem will ich lieber nicht spawn
hallo spawn please spawn
ok kann man nicht rein
was zum teufel das ist so chaotisches drecksgame
du blickst nicht durch in dem spiel
also noch ein Jahr battlefield 4
weiß nicht wenn du da auf battlefield 4 noch schafft bist
kannst du ja machen dann
mir wärs lieber gewesen sie hätten sich mit
hätten sie sich
ich finde so die würzen die würzen allen übel zu dieser misere so dass irgendwie die
nur merkwürdig ist dass battlefield 4 so früh gekommen ist sie hätten
battlefield 3 noch ein jahr leben lassen soll
was zum teufel ist hier los keiner da auf einmal ist von hinten gebashed
das letzte runde lief so geil
noch richtig schlecht
keine ahnung was da geht
das ist doch nicht oben der sporn oder
die anzeige stimmt doch überhaupt nicht wo der mich sporn
doch leute ich bin doch gerade komplett woanders gesporn als ich
angeklickt habe oder ich habe oben angeklickt und ich bin unten gesporn
der kaboom lebt doch gehe ich mal von außen ist auch schon eine weile her wo ich was von gehört habe
lohnt sich battlefield 4 noch schwierig zu sagen
also von den wellfield 4 ist das letzte gescheit
hat leider übrigens noch 300 spieler kein witz jetzt
und wo kommt das und wo kommt hier was und da oben ist eine flanke oder irgendwie sowas
die reaktion wie 2000 ergibt keinen sinn der satz egal wie reaktion wie keine ahnung mit 80
weil ich wollte eigentlich ein früheres datum als problem um so früheres datum ich sage
umso besser war die reaktion eigentlich deswegen ergibt es keinen sinn
es muss ja nicht alles hinzugeben was erzählte hat sie ja noch das overrated
sind ergeben schätzt sich das retten dauert viel zu lang viel viel zu lang
zum teufel ruckel ich will da durch alter scheiß movement system
oh gott es kann doch nicht sein dass sie immer noch auf die reihe kriegen
dass sie nicht dass sie immer an ihrem scheiß hängen bleibt das ist seit
battlefield 3 gibt es seit battlefield 3 ist das kaputt ich habe gesagt dass eine
alpha von battlefield 3 dass sie immer an dinge hängen bleibt das war in jedem
battlefield seit dem bisher so oder kurz licht anmachen
ok also über die sachen soll man vielleicht noch mal reden wenn das
gelten raus ist ich meine das ist das ist ja eine sache wo ich das das stempel
ich mal unter feinschliff ab aber halt so basics so wie die map zum beispiel
die werden sich ja immer großartig ändern
ich meine die map ist hingeschissen weiße farbe drüber und häuser drauf
fertig also dieses ich will den mapper gar nicht absprechen dass er da sogar
irgendwie viel energie reingesteckt hat so hübsch aussieht weil man muss bei die
skybox angucken die map sieht schon hübsch aus aber ich meine das ist doch
kein layout hier was ist denn das sieht da hinten aus wie flughafen oder so die
map sagt ja die map sagt richtig
mein megaborstack ich will dieses komische innen drüber springen das nervt
mich jetzt schon
das ist kein rush ach ne so ich hab mich verguckt
meins kann ich nicht aber das ist ja nur mal so zu den folgen das ist ich spiele
das weil es russ am ähnlichsten ist weil konquest konquest macht dem team schon
halbwegs bock aber es spielt sich halt komplett anders als wasch und mir
gefällt halt einfach so dass das rush und eventuell auch noch ein bisschen so
team desmatch wenn man sonst nichts zu tun hat aber rush gameplay gefällt mir
einfach das ist so most intense und da kann man auch am meisten mit machen mit
guten flanks und mit quasi wissen wie der gegner agiert auch man sieht
wie das die map wirklich einfach nur hingeschissen ist und weiß drüber
man hat halt hier nicht wirklich was hier kann von jeder von jeder zeit kann
jetzt den gegner auch recht um die ecke kommen ich muss sofort oder ist schon
einer acht oder den pficken weg von der zeit guck mal aber nein ich werde von
hinten gebashed und jetzt kriegst du immer den kill
man sieht auch die gegner schlecht da kommt doch was oder
so als mal Genex &
Hoppsi
Oh, Flank Action
Ich glaub das lohnt sich in dem Game nicht
Ich glaub Flank Action lohnt sich in dem Game nicht
Weil ich mein guck der Manuel vor allem mit der SMG
braucht er 3 Stunden, wenn ich da eingekillt hab
Achtung Achtung Achtung
Mein ist der Down
Übrigens, wie der wieder auf die Kiste geklettert ist, ne?
Direkt
Da lagt er
Der Informatiker
Oh
Oh, wa- was?
WTF? Wie hat er mich denn vor da getroffen? Alter
Die Map ist ähnlich wie Dem- ne, ne, ne, ne
überhaupt nicht wie Demoman Peak, Demoman Peak hast du überall Deckung
Ok, alles Down
Demoman Peak hast du überall Deckung, das am Anfang
Du hast vielleicht, vielleicht kann man das ein bisschen mit dem Anfang
von Demoman Peak gerade vergleichen, wo man von oben runter in die Base fahren muss
Aber, der große Unterschied ist, du musst von oben
runter in die Base fahren
und als Attacker
und hier ist der Attacker oben
was schonmal an sich fail ist
Attacker oben ist immer, ist immer sehr schwierig
und in Demoman Peak kannst du das eigentlich aber auch ganz gut machen
indem du einfach über die Felsen stellst
Ja, das ist überhaupt kein großes- du hast da eben Dem- du hast den Demoman Peak eigentlich ganz gut Deckung
Das war ein kipplichen Headshot
Wer's glaubt
Wo ist er?
Wo ist der da, Dude? Wo ist er?
Sagen wir mal, hier sind hier alle Down, kann ich es sagen?
Alles tot hier, ne?
Da kommt noch was
WAS?!
Von, von wo?!
Man, mein Gott ey, man hört nichts, man sieht nichts, man hat keine Ahnung von wo was kommt
Was ist das denn immer?
Kacke, ey
Ja guck mal, Leute, guck mal, im Chat, der beschwert sich zu Recht, absolut zu Recht, dass Medics nichts retzen
Das Problem ist, du kannst in diesem Game als Medic nichts wirklich retzen
Weil, sobald du retzt, bist du tot
Du kannst höchstens retzen, wenn einer stirbt am Ende des Fights, den du eh gewinnst
Dann kannst du retzen
Das ist so kaputt ey, das dauert viel zu lang
Warum kommt der Elite-Soldat hier nicht hoch?
Oh ne, ich hab hier noch ne Smoke, fuck
Ich seh nix, das kann übrigens...
Das ist so krass chaotisch, das macht mich fertig ey
Oh oh, ich muss hier weg, irgendwo hinter muss ich, dahinter, Felsen, Felsen, hinter Felsen muss ich
Übrigens, ich bin der Granat gerade
Weißt, wisst ihr, in Battlefield 3 konnte man sowas noch hochklatschen
Ich will hier doch einfach nur hoch
Jetzt werden sie gereckt, kaum ist man mal dran, werden sie ja auch weggefickt
Oh ne
Dann erstmal instant dauern
Die Musik ist hinter, die Hintergrundmusik ist ja nicht unpassend
Das beste Musik ist das, wir spawnen jetzt bei Battlefield 5 ist Kacke, der schon den passenden Namen für die Alpha hat
Also eins muss ich sagen, es fühlt sich besser an als Battlefield 1, so viel kann ich schon mal sagen
Das Problem war Battlefield 1 fand ich so beschissen, dass ich mir gar nicht gekauft hab
Und ich hatte den Code am Anfang, den hab ich nicht mehr eingelöst
So schlecht, stellt euch vor, ich hatte den Code zu Battlefield 1, ich hab ihn nicht eingelöst
So schlecht muss erstmal sein
Wie sollste im 9er pingen, 10er pingen, Leute, Grip, Grip, 10er pingen, 8er pingen, jetzt gehts wieder
Ich kann dich nicht retzen, Alter, das ist ein Problem, wenn ich den retze bin ich tot, höchstwahrscheinlich zumindest
Ja, Anzeige ist raus an die Telekom, 10er pingen, das geht ja gar nicht
10er pingen
10er pingen, ich glaub's nicht, ich soll dann sowas spielen
Er stirbt nicht, ok, ich muss mich mal kurz einsporken
Direkt, voll in die Eier gebadad
Ich hab keine Muni mehr, doch hab ich
Kann ich den retzen?
Oh, was ist jetzt los?
Ich blick mir mal durch, warum explodiert der gerade alles?
Und warum explodiert es vor mir, so dass ich nicht mehr in die Eier gebadade bin?
Und warum explodiert es vor mir, so dass ich nichts mehr sehe?
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt geht er wieder ab, der Max
Jetzt nichts
Hallo, bleibt nochmal stehen, bleibt nochmal ruhig stehen, dass ich noch schießen kann
Bleibt nochmal ruhig stehen, der wackelt die ganze Zeit
Dieses Movement, dieses hin und her geschwenken, das ist nicht weil ich wackel oder so
Das ist einfach weil der immer irgendwas macht
Einfach ruhig stehen bleiben und schießen kann halt nicht so schwer verlangt sein
Mal ein Rapidler, 18 oder 1
Aber jetzt läuft es schon wieder
14,4 kann man essen
Was macht, wenn das Game rauskommt und dann die kleinen Loops gebasht werden?
Jetzt ab
Zur Release machst du ein Duo des Todes, dann nehmen wir den da
Der Eaxe spielt bestimmt nicht
Die Hexe muss mitmachen
Dann nehmen wir noch irgendwie den Mesh oder so, damit dann
Gibt es so Rubbel Gameplays, da werden sie alle gebasht
Und die Weihnachtsnoobs werden auch nochmal gebasht im Dezember
Also quasi die ganzen Noobs, die gerne Noobs wären im Oktober werden im Dezember gebasht, wenn Weihnachten ist
Und die Agentin an Krills, Krills, das geht nicht
Grillfreies Squad
Die lenkt den Mesh sonst doch ab
Eaxe beim Noobs bashen, wenn das Game rauskommt
Ich besorge uns dann noch ein paar Kies, wenn es sich kaum willst und dann geht es ab
Was? Der ist einfach so, da bin ich tot
Oh, der geht ab, der Tür
Hallo, ich würde gerne Spawnen
Hallo, sterben
Nein, kein Bock
Das war overrated
Wie, du würdest nie aushalten bei dem Beat zu zocken, das ist das Beste, das Beste für alle Situationen
Gibt eigentlich keinen besseren Soundtrack, den du anmachen kannst
Bester Soundtrack aller Zeiten ist es
Wir können gleich noch andere Kirby Musik anmachen
WTF in diesem Scheisspiel, immer von der Kackzeit, immer
Jetzt guckst du in die Richtung, keiner da
Läufst lang, down
Das Lied läuft seit das Stream ab ist
So muss das sein
Lass mich Spawnen
Spawnen, Spawnen, Alter, B-Up, B-Up, ist Kacke
Entschod
Schreckt würde ich sagen
Oh, da kommt was, da kommt was
Ist das unter uns, ist das unter uns, oder?
Moment, von wo?
Ja, ihr könnt da gerne noch, ihr könnt da gerne noch mehr kommen, das ist schon ok, ne?
Achtung, Achtung
Krasser Rätsel
Wo ist er?
Wird gebashed, wird gebashed, alle gebashed wieder
In der Face
Keiner da
Next, too easy, next
Too easy, next
Jetzt spinn da rauf, ey
Oh, oh
Nope
Oh ne
Cracked
Too easy, next
Hier ist eine gute Camp-Ecke, wobei da können sie auch von der Seite brechen
Boah, wat?
Moment, Moment, wie das?
Was?
Wie ex?
Ah, nice, nice Rätsel
Ich hab übrigens keine Aufnahme laufen, ich kann die gameplays nicht mal für irgendwas verwenden
Alle die kleinen Fötzchen werden jetzt aber gebashed
Oh ne
Nein, FSK 18 Tor, werden jetzt aber gebashed
Ah, das, das ging ab, das war ein nicer Run
Sehr nice Run
Gleich weiter Sporn
Und wir müssen da lang, wir müssen da lang, jetzt kommen wir nicht von hier
Ah, Moment, warum, warum?
Wir müssen da lang, wir müssen da lang, jetzt kommen wir nicht von hier.
Moment, warum, warum? Das ist doch kacke.
Das ist scheiße, was soll das hier überhaupt?
Jetzt dürfen wir, oder? Jetzt dürfen wir jetzt hoch. Und jetzt ist hier wieder Feuer. Warum ist jetzt Feuer?
Weg, weg! Oh fuck. Klingen die Waffen wie in Kot? Naja, das ist eine MP40, die klingt in allen zweiten Weltkriegspielen ungefähr ähnlich.
Sonst wäre es ja auch ganz schön blöd, wenn die gleiche Waffe nicht ungefähr gleich klingt.
Ansonsten ist Sound in Battlefield eigentlich in der Regel immer deutlich besser als in Kot. Also das kriegen sie von Rice wirklich gut her.
Da kann man nichts sagen. Da will ich, ich will bei Peps nicht spawnen. Ich will bei...
Da gibt es ja nur Peps. Peps hat eine kacke Pose.
Guck mal, kacke Pose hat er. Alter, dieses Game, Spawn stirbst, Spawn stirbst, ey.
Ich merke immer, wenn ich anfange in einem Game besser zu werden, dann guck ich immer Stats. Ich hab immer Stats geguckt. Stats, Stats, Stats.
Immer Stats. Wo stellst du denn der Typ rum? Er hat rumgestellt. Naja, ich spawn da oben.
Pence man. Ja, auf fahr.
Kann man hier vielleicht was drehen mit...
Außer dass man geschneit wird von der Seite.
Ahnung, für 60 berg runter kann da nichts passieren. Wisst ihr, ihr sie überlebt.
So geht das. Pro Stats.
Kriegt euch nicht über die Musik, auf die Musik ist das beste.
Das ist Highline quasi. Weil das Game ist nicht das Highline.
Zu viel. Vorsicht, dass da noch einer ist.
Wir sind nicht mehr auf 5, das geht nicht.
Nein, nicht sterben, Alter, nicht sterben.
Was ist der Typ denn? Der ist ein voller Arsch der Welt.
Passt. Gehen wir mal hier vorsichtig unten gucken, was hier los ist.
Irgendwie haben wir die letzten 10 Runden gewonnen, oder? Äh, nicht 10, aber die letzten 5.
Vergleich zu dem Kackanfang.
Oh nee, das ist die letzte Base, wo die Gegner wieder hinter einem spawnen.
Guck da, da spawnen sie schon wieder hinter einem. Ich krieg zu viel.
Von wo hat es mich beschossen?
Ich blicke hier nicht durch. Ich blicke nicht durch, das ist zu unübersichtlich.
Von wo kommt hier was?
Das Ding knackelt aber schon ganz schön.
Oh, Munition alle.
Alter, wie viel soll ich dem noch damage machen?
Hallo, ich bin übrigens gestuck, nicht, dass ihr denkt, ich bin einfach so rum stehen geblieben.
Das ist mega unübersichtig, das Game, das macht mich mental, das macht mich fertig.
Das ganze Game macht mich übelst fertig.
Guck mal, du bist wieder belebt und auf einmal hast du 30 Gegner um dich drum herum.
Und dann hast du keine Munition und du hast keine Ahnung, wo es Munition gibt.
Ich brauch jetzt irgendwo Muni her. Nein, hier nicht.
Und jetzt slide in die falsche Richtung.
Ich hätte ja einfach die Muni klauen können, wenn sie mich wiederbeleben.
So richtig, so richtig Teamplayer Style.
Ich brauch Munition.
Munition, please give Munition.
Das war doch etwas. Ist das Muni? Munition.
Alter, GIF.
Von wo? Von hinten.
Der pieps, aber wir haben 48, 43, 10.
Battle for 5 ist kacke, hat das Squad verlassen.
Kennst du den neuen Ninja-Skandal?
Also ich kenne weder den neuen Ninja-Skandal noch den alten Ninja-Skandal.
Vielleicht wäre es ganz gut, kannst du mir erstmal den alten Ninja-Skandal erklären.
Aber erstmal den alten Ninja-Skandal, dass ich den neuen Ninja-Skandal besser einordnen kann.
Oh, das ist ein Panzer. Pantsman.
Ich musste wiederbeleben.
Das ist der beste.
Alter, man ist 30 Milliarden Stunden gestunt.
Und dann in 5 Gegnern drin.
Wer ist Ninja? Einen muss man nicht kennen, der hat nur 100.000 Zuschauer.
Oder ich kenne es.
Overrated.
Das Game von allen Seiten.
Ey du Sporz bist droht, Sporz bist droht von allen Seiten. Du weißt ganz gut, wo du hin gucken sollst.
Was? Er sagt, er streamt nicht mit Grills und irgendwelche Leute triggert das. Es sind heutzutage wegen allem, wegen allem sind Leute getriggert.
Ich habe doch vorhin auch gesagt, so etwas wie in der Richtung Grill-freies Squad.
Da wären auch schon wieder, wenn es die falschen Leute gehörte, dann wären die instan triggert gewesen.
So wie Manspreading. Oh, das ist auch so was.
Du sitzt ja in der Bahn bequem da. Das liegt nicht daran, dass du als Mann bequem da sitzen willst.
Nein, das ist weil du männliche Dominanz demonstrieren möchtest.
Was sonst?
Aber ja, kommt schon auf die, die als Kerl bequem da sitzen wollen. Das kann nicht sein.
Und dann gibt es Leute, die erfinden sowas wie Manspreading.
Allein schon das Wort ist so beknackt.
Triggert, aber richtig triggert er.
Alter, hör auf durch die Wand zu schießen. Warum schießt du durch die Wand? Warum schießt du durch die Wand?
Er hat gleich durch die Wand geschossen.
EU-Aim. Das war eben EU-Aim, muss man echt sagen.
Und das geile ist, heute hat ja auch der Manspreading getrendet auf Twitter.
Und das lustige war, da waren ganz viele, das muss man sich jetzt mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen.
Da waren ganz viele Bilder dabei von Leuten, die quasi Typen, die mit relativ gespralzten Beinen in der S-Bahn da gesessen haben.
Haben die fotografiert. Jetzt überlegt euch mal, überlegt euch mal, was los wäre, wenn ich Weiber fotografieren würde.
Jetzt habe ich das ja schon wieder triggert.
Wenn ich, ähm, äh, holde, holde, ähm, jungfräuliche Damen fotografieren würde in der Bahn, die in etwas unglücklicher Pose da sitzen.
Das wäre ja, das wäre ja Instant-Gefängnis, Instant-Jail wäre das.
Aber wenn man den Typ fotografiert, der Manspreader, das ist okay.
Dann kann man ein bisschen Shame öffentlich auf Twitter, das ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Ha, das hast du dir so gedacht, ne?
Da falle ich nicht drauf rein, ne?
Okay, ich weiß nicht, wo hier was kommt, kommt hier überhaupt was?
Ja, da kommt was.
Äh, ich wollte übrigens gar nicht runter.
Ich wollte doch, warum ist das Animationssystem teilweise so scheiße?
Der ist jetzt runtergehächtet. Ich wollte überhaupt nicht, ich wollte einfach runtergucken.
Tattoo ist auch am Start, jetzt sind's aber alle da hier.
Und das Schlimme ist, dass man sogar jetzt aufpassen muss.
Ich meine, ich bin hier am Spielen, labere in den Scheiß und sogar da nehmen das Leute ernst, wenn ich Scheiße erzähle, ja?
Das ist total bescheuert.
Also wisst ihr, der Milchmein, ich mach das immer zu, ich mach das auch übelst asozial im Zug, immer.
Ich stell immer meinen Rucksack neben mir, immer.
Ich setz mich hin, Rucksack, zack.
Dann mach ich so den Arm um den Rucksack und ich, also sag mal so, wenn mich einer fragt, mach ich das weg.
Klar, natürlich mach ich das weg, wenn mich einer fragt.
Easy, best squad eats, two eats, two eats.
Ähm, klar mach ich das weg, wenn mich einer fragt.
Aber ansonsten liegt das einfach da, weil ich keinen Bock hab, dass sich Leute neben mich setzen und die machen sich meistens so breit.
Und ich kann mir einfach besseres vorstellen, als morgens im Zug.
Es ist warm, ich hab immer kurze Hose an morgens.
Ich lauf dann auf die Arbeit vom Südbahnhof aus.
Und ich hab keinen Bock, wenn dann, das ist voll gay irgendwie so.
Weiß nicht, wenn dann dann so mit, jeweils so Oberschenkel aneinander reibst im Zug.
So, weil der andere auch nur kurze Hose an hat und sich breit machen muss.
Wie wird der Fabian jetzt sagen?
Homo Fürst.
Oh nein, triggert, oh Gott, schon wieder.
Schon wieder triggert.
Aber ich will nicht mit fremden Leuten meine Oberschenkel reiben im Zug.
Weder, weder mit Typen, noch mit Grylls.
Gar nicht, ich will mit keine Oberschenkel reiben im Zug.
Die nehmen wir mit sitzen.
Warum nicht? Ja, war ja auch nicht. Warum nicht? Gute Fahrer.
Weil ich körperlichen Kontakt mit fremden Leuten nicht abkann.
Ich hab ja schon Probleme mit Kontakt mit Leuten, die ich kenne, ja.
Und auch mit Leuten, die ich gut kenne, ich hab sie nicht so mit.
Körperlichen Berührungen.
Oh, guck mal, der Spawn, der Spawn, wieder voll in die Gehschlager.
Okay, wenigstens was gekillt. Mehr kann man bei dem Spawn machen.
Fynn, bist du dieses Jahr auf der Gamescom?
Bist du im EA-Business-Bereich, wo du Captchern kannst?
Hat er heute so geschrieben.
Weil, wenn nicht, würde ich das machen, aber dann bist du bestimmt eh schon.
Da kann man wenigstens sitzen in Ruhe.
Captchern. Oder einfach nur sitzen und so tun als Captchern, Mann.
MP40, beste.
Ja, unterhalten im Zug hab ich keine Probleme.
Unterhalten tue ich mich mit manchen Leuten im Zug auch ganz gerne.
Vor allem ist es witzig zu sehen, wenn die Bahnverspätung hat,
wie uns die sich auf einmal alle einig sind.
Aber es ist so unterschiedlich, ob man sich unterhält oder Oberschenkel reibt.
Und aufs Oberschenkel rein mache ich dir so viel Spaß.
Ich habe übrigens gemerkt, es reicht schon bei einem E-Trick.
Man muss gar nicht vorher auf die Spritze switchen.
High-Octane-Tips and Tricks.
Ich sehe nichts. Ich sehe nichts.
Von der Seite. Dieses Drecks-Spiel. Immer wirst du von der Seite gekillt.
Immer.
Battlefield 5 ist kacke.
Der auf dem ersten Platz hat Recht.
Gamescom ist mir viel zu voll. Ja, Milchmann ist auch so.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich keinen Bock habe.
Viel zu voll und eigentlich kommt auch zu wenig bei rum.
Hallo, ich will spawnen. Spawnen.
In dem Game sitzt du ja echt einen halben Tag im Spawn-Bildschirm.
Kannst nichts machen.
Aber das ist nur, weil die Noobs wieder gesagt haben,
oh mein Gott, da ist so viel los, dann stirbt man ja direkt beim Spawnen.
Das geht nicht. Das kann überhaupt nicht sein.
Ich will nicht sterben beim Spawnen.
Da müsste ich ja aufpassen, wo ich spawne. Das geht nicht.
Die Dice-Logik ist, um die Noobs nicht zu verschrecken,
kann man jetzt gar nicht spawnen, anstatt dass man überlegen muss,
aber das geht ja nicht.
Hallo, sterben, please.
Ich kann dich nicht retzen.
Ich würde dich gerne retzen, kann ich aber nicht, weil ich dann selbst sterbe.
Das ist auch nice-design-Entscheidung.
Was macht der da?
Finn, wie machst du das?
Retzt du Leute immer auch auf die Gefahr,
dass du selbst auf den Sack kriegst oder sagst du einfach, mach was ihr wollt?
Also ich fand es in Battlefield 3 geil, wenn Leute gespawned sind
und ich auf einen geschossen habe, weil in der Regel wurden die instant beschreckt.
Also die sind immer gespawned. Du hast da quasi schon Dauerfeuer drauf,
drauf mit einem M16, M416 oder so. Die sind gespawned, hatten zwei Sekunden Spawnschutz
und bis die sich versehen haben, waren die auch im Arsch.
Warum keine Facecam? Ich mach Katzencam, kann ich gern machen.
Meine Katze sah gestern aus wie Spidercat.
Spidercat hier war komplett voll mit Spinnenweben.
Alter, Gegner von allen Seiten, geh ich los.
Überall geh ich noch, guckt es euch an.
Wo sollen wir denn jetzt hin?
Was, was, what the fuck?
Okay, das war ein A-Aim, das kann das Game nicht für.
Muss man ja auch mal sagen, wenn man nicht trifft, ist es schon okay.
Das war einfach nicht getroffen jetzt. Die Runde ist verdammt kacke.
Die eine Runde war einfach übelst geil, mit 38, 8 oder so am Ende.
Das ging ab.
Aber irgendwie reißt ja keiner was gerade.
Ich weiß nicht wo ich hingucken soll, weil die Fronten in dem Game nicht klar sind.
Da flankt garantiert einer jetzt.
Oder auch nicht.
Schön mal Spritze in die Schulter und alles ist wieder gut.
Nice Immersion.
Meine Immersion.
Da war doch einer eben.
Hä, what the fuck, was war das?
Was war das? Ach der hat gebaut, der hat gebaut, das war das geile Baufeature.
Okay, hier kann man nicht reinkriechen, wobei geht nicht.
Direkt im Kopf, voll im Kopf.
Ich muss mal weg.
Also für dich, dass ich monatlang nicht gespielt hab, finde ich, die Läufe sind eigentlich ganz okay.
Von hinten, von wo sonst, wir sind ja Battlefield 5, da wird man eh mal von hinten gauend.
Spawn, spawn, spawn, spawn
Ich kann nirgendswo spawnen
Nice shaky effect
Jump at will
Das muss dar, stehnt das
Als würde ich jetzt auf die Idee kommen zu sagen
Ach ne, also eigentlich will ich doch nicht spawnen
Ich kann weapon, spawnen ist immer so stressig
Spawn ist overrated
Ich will nicht spawnen
Guck mal da sitzt ein und da sitzt was
Im Busch hat er gesessen, habt ihr ihn gesehen?
Er hat mich aber gesehen
Direkt
Oh, der ist down
Ja das ist die optimale Musik für die Fahrzeug Games
Ist so, ist die Wahrheit
Moment kann es sein, dass wir das Ding hier planten müssen?
Ich checks wieder nicht
Ich hab ja immer nicht die Objectives kapiert
Aber ich will bashen, bashen ist
Eindeutig wichtiger als Gegner als Objectives machen
Alter
Kannst du mal verrecken
Next
Oh nee, siehst du?
Scheiß Revive Animation
Bist du auf der Gamescom?
Nee bin ich nicht
Zu voll
Lohnt sich zu
Oh haben wir gewonnen?
Ah wir haben gewonnen
Zu voll eigentlich
Zu wenig was sich lohnt
Das ist eigentlich geil an der Gamescom
War eigentlich immer, dass man mal ein paar Leute wieder sieht
Wie findest du das Game bis jetzt?
Also um ehrlich zu sein eigentlich ziemlich kacke
Aber besser als Battlefield 1
Aber das ist auch keine Kunst
Viel besser als Battlefield 1
Battlefield 1 war für mich der absolute Tiefpunkt
Das war so fail
Battlefield 3
Battlefield 3 kann beste
Battlefield 4 auch gut
Hardline vergessen
Battlefield 1 sacked
Battlefield 5
Sack ein Ticken äh weniger
Das wars dann auch
Wir machen wieder unseren geilen Flank
Wisst ihr Leute der hat das letzte
Der klappt immer gut der Flank
Oh nee der hat uns gesehen
Der hat uns gesehen
Scheiße der hat uns gesehen
Egal
Der Mega Flank ist es
Bester Flank
Sag euch doch bester Flank
Jetzt sagt mal was anderes ey
Ein nicer Flank war das ein sehr sehr nicer Flank
Jetzt müssen sie irgendwie wieder hier hoch oder
Seh ich das richtig
Alter wie die rumschreien
Der Master Flank so ja
Ich weiß ja immer nicht von wo in dem Jahr
Ich wäre ich ja gerätzt wenn ich Glück habe
Aber ich glaube die sind auch alle down
Geile Schneiber da ist er
Oh Schneiber Grill sorry
Ich wollte keine männliche Dominanz demonstrieren
Weil ich das nicht erkannt habe
Sorry nicht Trigger sein please
Was
Ich denke wir haben den Sektor
Kann man in dem Game eigentlich auch
Runterspringen Fallschirm aufmachen geht das
Wäre nämlich ganz praktisch jetzt
Da vorne ist ein Gegner
Fuß
Kann man hier durch
Oh nice
Next
Wo genau kommen die jetzt eigentlich her
Wo kommen die dann da wahrscheinlich
Jetzt läuft Sonne ein bisschen einspielend
Ordentlich
Sollte nicht eigentlich Auszone sein
Jetzt ist Sporn Rape
Die Map ist komisch aufgebaut
Ich meine
Immer von
Von wo immer von wo wird man hier immer
Gekillt
Erster so muss das sein
So mache ich das
Jeder hat die Alfa in dem Fall
Ich habe schon offene
Close Tests gesehen
Die ist tatsächlich relativ close
Diese nicht abschaltbaren Kletter animation
Ich habe die Nate gesehen
Ich habe sie gesehen
Ich habe die Timer nicht gecheckt
Ich dachte der bugged
Ich dachte der Timer bugged
Weil es nicht explodiert ist
Aber das ist eine Übungssache
Ist ja nichts
Action
Verarscht
Debated
Ist nichts oder
Unter mir ist was
Die werden wir uns überraschen
Bisschen viel
Das war ein bisschen viele Gegner
Das war 5 Stück oder so
Ich glaube ich muss hoch
Kann es sein das ist ein Nidor Sporn
Wo man immer ein bisschen anders
Von wo
Der 5 ist Kacke
Hab ich oft genug gesehen
Das war noch was
Der Halsball müsste präsenter sein
Wenn man in die Mitte vom Bildschirm guckt
Das ist einer von mir
Sagen gibt es
Ich habe es mitgekriegt
Die Werbe Kampagne gestartet
So dass sie jetzt voll die weiße Weste haben
Quasi nur das beste wollen
Für ihre Leute
Das beste Facebook aller Zeiten
Habt ihr die Werbung auch schon mal gekriegt
Weil Facebook
Ist vorbei
Dass die jemals niemand markt Facebook zu benutzen
Niemand keiner markt Facebook zu benutzen
Alle benutzen die für alle die Facebook benutzen
Benutzen Facebook bloß weil das ist was alle anderen auch
Keiner mag das
Das ist ein bisschen wie Skype früher
Nur auf andere andere
Kategorie
Skype war auch so das ungeschriebene Gesetz
Bis dann jedenfalls einer ein gescheites Discord gemacht hat
Er steht da doch ich sehe den da oder
Skype war mal gut
Ja das stimmt
Am Anfang war Skype ganz brauchbar
Gut
Kennt das überhaupt noch jemand
Ja wieder von der Seite
Kennt noch jemand ICQ
Das ist komplett outdated aber komplett
Aber es gibt es noch
Kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen
ICQ gibt es noch
Ich konnte meine ICQ nochmal auswählen ich damals
Heute immer noch
Ich sag dir nicht
Können wir danach suchen
Feststellen wo ich früher alles dummes Zeug gepostet habe
Die Gegner kommen jetzt auch wieder
Die Gegner kommen halt auch wieder voll in die Seite
Das Problem ist ich weil die die Helz ist so unpräsent
Man sieht gar nicht ob man jetzt seine
Seinen Helzpack aufgenommen hat oder nicht
Schau mal die Spritze in die Schulter
Wie sieht es eigentlich wie Killstreaks aus
Haben wir da mal ein paar Starbacks da
Finn weißt du das in die Killstreaks ist das Squad
Squad oder ist das Einzel Performance
Das heißt mein Squad sackt um es auf gut Deutsch zu sagen
Weil wir keinen Killstreak haben
Was haben die sich eigentlich mit den Spawns gedacht
Das sage ich jetzt jede Runde
Ich meine man muss da was capturen
Man muss links und rechts was capturen
Hat er aber die Gegner Spawns
Was ist das da ist
Warum baut man sowas
Der Hard Carry ist am Start
Endlich
Wir haben wieder Carry im Battlefield
Next
Einmal ein 34 10
Das kann schon sehen lassen
Was ich monatelang net gespielt habe
Nix eigentlich so richtig
Das letzte Battlefield auch schon wieder 2 Jahre
3 Jahre her oder so
Beste Musik
Morgen wieder
Morgen geht es weiter
Morgen mache ich da nicht Kirby's Gourmet Race an
Sondern Kirby's
Kirby's Streamland
Seam Song vom Gameboy Advance
Ist das Deal
Alter
Haben wir Deal
Morgen gibt es dann Kirby Gameboy Advance Musik
Wenn ihr sagt nee
Stream ich morgen nicht
Ganz einfach
Da ist ein Panzer
Panzmann ist am Start
Achtung wir stürmen jetzt voll von der Seite rein
Yolo
Massiv Yolo
Hat man eigentlich Mehle
Ah Fuck
Ich wollte ihn Mehlen
Habt ihr gesehen ich habe ihn gemessert
Ich wollte es ausprobieren
Anstatt zu schießen hätte ich geschossen
Hätte ich links und da ohne
Man müsste jetzt mal ausprobieren
Allein schon dass ich auf so Optimierungsideen
Kommt kann das Game nicht allzu schlecht sein
Also
Nee Nee
DPS rein schießen ist definitiv besser als
Schießen Mehle Schießen Mehle
Mehle klar
Mehle
Komm her Alter
Das ist eine nice Runde jetzt die zweite Hälfte oder
Ihr müsst dazu geben
Das ist schon eine nice Runde jetzt
Ok das war jetzt verkackt aber
Ah 40 12 geht doch
Kann man auch so lassen
Ich will spawnen
Ich würde gerne spawnen das ist schon gut
Moment an was an was sterbe ich gerade wieder
Ich sterbe woran
Ich verstehe das Game nicht
Echt
43 13 so muss das sein
Also über Gameplay kann man es doch heute nicht
Beschweren oder
Flutsch doch 43 13
Etzi
Ich wollte euch noch den Gaming Tisch zeigen
Falls du noch da bist hast du auch
Eine Anfrage bekommen ob du nicht
Einen
RGB Gaming Tisch
Vorstellen willst
Ich könnte mir vorstellen die haben alle Leute
Angeschrieben
Was sagst du zu diesem Tisch
Moin
Ja ja kontinue
Ich habe noch eine Frage an euch
Falls ich damit jemand auskennt
Kennt ihr eine gute
Outdoor Kamera
Um die haustür aufzunehmen
Also sprich das müsste was sein was
Was man
Quasi per per POE versorgen kann oder halt
Oder halt wireless und dann
Weil es für Daten übertragen
Ja ja ist ja gut
Jetzt habe ich aufgepasst
Ich muss gerade was gucken
So nur aber
Da ist er
Auch wie ich 0 1 habe
Weil ich rechtzeitig aus dem
Flugzeug bin
Du konntest ganz stimmt ich konnte nicht
Spingen
Bester Weg hier
Von hinten in diesem Scheiß
Game immer von hinten
Das Ding hat keine frontline das
Game
Aber wir hatten heute schon so ultra
Geile Runden
Da können wir uns echt nicht
Beschweren
Was war das letzte 45 11 oder so
War schon
War das richtig
Hallo
Das war eine halbe Stunde vor seinem
Kopf rum gewackelt mit mit dem
Ironside habt ihr das gesehen
Da war echt eine halbe Stunde
Vor dem Kopf
Hör ich jetzt eigentlich Spaß
Es ist ne eigentlich sagt das Game
Das Game macht nur Bock wenn man
Gegner best und Games die nur Bock
Machen wenn man das Gegner best
Aber ich bin jetzt zumindest gewillt
Nachdem ich jetzt heute ein bisschen
Das genauer angeguckt habe bin jetzt
Mindest gewillt
Dem Game noch mal eine Chance zu
Gehen auf
Der anderen
Und mit ein bisschen mehr
Klassen und Zeug
Ich meine die Runden die geilen
Runden die wir heute hatten mit 40
Plus Kills das war schon ein
War schon hat schon Bock gemacht
Aber wie gesagt jedes Game macht
Bock wenn man best
Ist einfach so
Ja das
Das habe ich auch gesehen das Ding
Mein Problem ist also mit mit der
Kamera ich will das ich will auch
Nehmen wer klingelt
Beziehungsweise wer vom Hoftor steht
Das Problem ist das ist Gehweg das
Heißt ich kann eigentlich nicht den
Gehweg aufnehmen
Also ich kann schon aber eigentlich
Darf man nicht den Gehweg aufnehmen
Das heißt
Ich sehe nichts
Das heißt eigentlich bleibt mir nur
Was im Gang im Gang
Wo ich da nicht die Pistole klingeln
Sehe oder was kleines versteckt ist
Dass es keiner sieht dass ich den
Eingang aufnehme dann beschwert sich
Keiner
Das hat zwei Gründe ich will nicht
Ich will ersten sehen wenn
Merkwürdige Leute vor der Tür stehen
Auf die ich keinen Bock habe da kann
Ich dann afk faken also dass ich weg
Bin faken und ich will mal gucken was
DHL und Hermes so treibt
Die nämlich angeblich immer die
Sachen zustellen obwohl während ich
Da bin und ich nicht da bin
Ok warum auch immer da jetzt kein
Hitmarker dabei war ich war es nicht
Da war er ich habe ihn gesehen
Wir smokeen uns mal
Ne wir smokeen uns mal nicht
Das war blöd mit der SMG auf
Irgend so ein Reifel Duell einzulassen
Und das Problem ist ich kann das auch
Nicht an die Klingel direkt machen
Weil unser Klingel ist so ein Kack Set
Von ihm zu einem
Von ihm zum komischen Hersteller
Wo man ganz eigene Dinger wieder macht
Und so wo man nicht durchblickt
Gibt es hier ein gutes Squad noch
Fox bestes
Hallo Joy
Warum geht das nicht
Was ist das denn
Warum kann ich hier rein
Musst du ja muss ich muss ich an
Eingang
Die Sache ist die
Ich will eigentlich nur wissen wer
Vor der wer vom Eingang steht
Das heißt am besten etwas
Unauffälliges was man gar nicht
So richtig sieht dass ich auch
Keiner beschweren kann
Ich will ja gar nichts wirklich
Großartig auswerten oder so mit der Kamera
Also ich will ich was heißt auswerten
Ich will ja nichts großartig aufzeichnen
Und und und
Fakes Analyse oder so
Ich will einfach nur gucken ob
DHL was hingeschmissen hat
Und sagen sie war nicht da oder so
Oder ich war nicht da
Und ob komische Leute vor der Tür stehen
Das ist ja eigentlich mein einziges Ziel
So Leute genug Battlefield
Reicht für heute 21 Uhr in der Stunde
Ich zeige euch jetzt noch den
Gaming Tisch
Display Capture
Wie ist das Ding dann
Ja genau
Passt mal auf
Das ist der Gaming das
Ich finde das Ding sieht irgendwie sehr
Wackelig und billig aus
Der Ultra Desk
So
Wie ich gesagt habe sieht aus wie ein
Alienberg Gehäuse als Tisch
Und irgendwie überzeugt mich dieses
Produkt nicht so richtig
Weil da verdammt sind also
Für mich kommt es auf keinen Fall
In Frage weil ich bin mit meinem
Setup zufrieden ich habe keinen Bock
Umzubauen
Außerdem brauche ich was
Höhenverstellbares
Aber
Mal wenn wir jetzt mal von ausgehen
Ich bräuchte einen Tisch
Vom Ansatz her einen Gaming Tisch zu
Machen finde ich nicht verkehrt
Aber
Es ist so
So unklar alles
Ich meine was genau soll dann sein
Von wo steht es denn hier mit
Ingenieuren steht doch hier irgendwie
Irgendwo
Hier
Entwickelt von europäischen
Ingenieuren
Was genau soll mir das jetzt sagen
Ich bestell beispielsweise relativ
Viel bei AliExpress
Und das ist garantiert nicht von
Europäischen Ingenieuren
Aber das Zeug ist trotzdem billig und gut
Übrigens
Jetzt nicht nachgucken Leute nicht
Nachgucken ratet mal was es kostet
Ratet mal was es kostet
Ich sage euch der Preis geht für einen
Ordentlichen Tisch in Ordnung
Ja aber ratet mal ich weiß halt nicht
Ob es dafür in Ordnung geht
Aber ratet mal was es kostet
Ihr könnt jetzt noch mal ahnen
Was es in Ordnung ist
Ultradex also guck mal
RGB
RGB irgendwie nur hier oder auch hier
Das ist auch etwas was ich eben
Geschrieben habe
Was ich nicht so ganz checke
Hier sieht so aus als ist RGB nur da
Und da aus irgendwelchen Gründen
Das war quasi in unsinnigsten
Stellen überhaupt
Aber hier sieht so aus
Als wäre der ganze Tisch RGB
Aber das hier ist eigentlich nur so
Einen Fake
Der nur so aussieht als ob
Ah ja übrigens der Tisch kostet
Der ist richtig
Falls er nicht geguckt hat
Aber wahrscheinlich hat er geguckt
Gesunde Ergonomie
Das ist auch etwas was ich
Ihnen geschrieben habe
Sie schreiben mir zum Beispiel
Formen orientieren sich an
Ergebnisse von wissenschaftlichen
Untersuchungen
Welche denn
Wenn es doch welche gibt
Dann schreibt es doch hin
Geräumige Tischplatte
Na gut
Also das ist ja eigentlich
Das ist der Grund warum ich mir
einen Tisch hole
Das sollte man nicht als
Pluspunkt aufführen müssen
Räumige Tischplatte
Das hat einen Tisch zu haben
Dafür ist er da
So ein stabiler Rahmen
Und ich finde das sieht
Nicht sonderlich stabil aus
Ich habe mir auf YouTube
Ein paar Unpacked
In zwei Unboxings angeguckt
Und ich finde
Dass der Tisch nicht
Sonderlich stabil aussehen
Ich glaube von IMEA
Habe ich mir das angeguckt
So guck mal
Der wackelt jetzt an dem Tisch
Guck mal
Seht ihr
Seht ihr wie der Tisch
Rutscht und wackelt
Seht ihr es
Warte mal
Er wackelt
Er wackelt gleich noch am Tisch
Er wackelt am Ende am Tisch
Also es sieht
Es sieht sehr
Ich meine
What the fuck
Ja guck mal
Seht ihr wie das wackelt
Das ist doch nicht stabil
So
Aber ich habe ihnen
Mein Feedback schon
Per Mail zukommen lassen
Sogar mit Verbesserungsvorschlägen
Ja das ist das
Das wirklich
Also mehr geht nicht
Ich habe ihnen zum Beispiel
Geschrieben, dass ich es
Für sinnvoll halte
Wenn sie anstatt
Anstatt
Entwickelt von europäischen
Ingenieuren
Wenn sie machen würden
Oben entlinkt das Team
Hinter Ultra Desk
Na dann hat man
Ein bisschen
Übrigens was das da hinten ist
Verstehe ich auch nicht
Hat jemand eine Ahnung
Was das hier ist
Dieses unförmige
Carbon Style Tuch
Welche Firma
Steht hier an diesem Tisch
Hab ich noch nie gehört
Wartet mal
Cyber Level GmbH
In Polen
Piotra Noblima
Ne
Ist die Adresse
Tja
Müssen wir mal nachgucken
Wer da der Geschäftsführer
Geschäftsführerin ist
Kundenbindung ganz in deutscher Sprache
Nachdem sie gerade so witzig sind
Sind sie schon mal
Nicht so weit weg von der ESL
Wahrscheinlich haben sie
Sogar noch etwas damit zu tun
Keine Ahnung
Aber ich bin davon irgendwie
Oh die haben Facebook
Gucken wir uns jetzt mal an
Ne
Fake
Fake Facebook
Gibt's gar nicht
Ja
Also hat mich jetzt nicht so überzeugt
Ehrlich gesagt
Hat mich nicht so überzeugt
Okay
Was zum Teufel ist Unleashed
Windows 10
Haha
Lul
Microsoft
Unleashed
Windows 10
Und es ist ein Fehler aufgetreten
Lul 3D
Ich muss das Memeboard starten
Wo ist es denn
Wo ist das Memeboard
Es ist kaputt
Geht's jetzt
Das Memeboard ist broken
Ah jetzt geht's
Microsoft Fail oder
Das müssen wir übrigens auch mal
Endlich fertig machen
Was hier komplett Mindblown angesagt ist
So Leute ich muss
In 45 Minuten muss ich pennen gehen
Das heißt wir machen ja Schluss
Ich guck mal kurz in die
Follows noch mal rein
Ich hoffe euch hat's gefallen
Oh so viele Follows
Ich seh leider plus die letzten paar
Der Handbowl
Cartor
HSI
Shenxi
Impactic
Irgendwie Imreptic
TheBoneSlasher
Katsma
Saat
Core
Laser
Prezi
WWE
Fritz
Mehr seh ich leider nicht
Vielleicht warten es auch alle
Danke für die Follows
Beats Clap
Die APDF
Ich trau mich da nicht rein zu gucken
Weil ich nicht weiß was es ist
Das würde ich jetzt
Onstream aufmachen
Ich weiß nicht was es ist
Nicht dass ich jetzt was falsches
Zeige hier Onstream
Ich machs lieber nicht auf
EAPMG kann ich zeigen
EAPMG ist der Anfang vom
Bullshit Bingo Board
Für die E3
Ja Leute
Ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen
Wir machen Schluss
Machts gut
Bis zum nächsten Mal
Tschüss
See you
Und hört euch mal ein bisschen
Klaue Musik an